[Musique]
Éric deessé, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Euh, je m'appelle Éric de Nessé. Je suis
un breton du Morbillant, euh géographe
et politologue de formation avec une
spécialité sur le sud-est asiatique. Euh
un séjour dans le renseignement sur la
fin de la guerre froide où j'ai
notamment été en charge de de ces
questions. une expérience opérationnelle
dans les maquillis au Cambodge. après ça
un séjour dans le secteur privé,
industrie d'armement, société de
formation et de conseils militaire,
société de sécurité militaire et puis
depuis plus de 25 ans dans le
renseignement économique avec en
parallèle, je pense qu'il nous intéresse
ce soir, la création d'un fingtong
consacré au renseignement qui s'appelle
le Centre français de recherche sur le
renseignement qui a principalement trois
missions. changer le regard de la
société française sur le renseignement,
avoir un impact auprès des autres des
parties prenantes au politique publique,
c'est avoir des possibilités de former
nos parlementaires, nos hommes
politiques sur ces questions que
finalement ils connaissent très mal et
puis faire en sorte aussi d'avoir une
action vis-à-vis de la société civile
pour que l'image de ce métier hautement
utile soit enfin reconnu dans nos pays
comme il est dans les pays anglo-saxons.
Et ben, on va parler renseignement
économique.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de l'état de
du renseignement français ? Est-ce que
le renseignement français, tant
renseignement économique que
renseignement de terrain est est
opérationnel, effectif, proactif ? Je
vois un petit sourire quand je dis
proactif.
Ouais. Non, il y a il y a aujourd'hui à
la fois des choses extrêmement positives
et des choses qui qu'ils sont qu'ils
sont moins. On doit reconnaître que
depuis euh 2013, depuis les les séries
d'attentats qu'on a connu, il y a eu
quand même beaucoup de choses qui ont
été faites, aussi bien en matière de
recrutement, euh de budget, euh parfois
d'organisation, de lois. Donc il y a eu
enfin pour la première fois presque dans
l'histoire de France une vraie prise de
conscience du rôle du renseignement. Je
dirais malheureusement, c'est une prise
de conscience qui relève plus du
principe de précaution que de la
véritable reconnaissance de l'utilité
des services. Maintenant, il y a un
certain nombre de défauts qu'on trouve
aujourd'hui dans les services français
mais qu'on va trouver à peu près partout
dans les services occidentaux, c'est que
les services augmentent en effectif. Ça
génère un des problèmes de technocratie
assez classique dès qu'une organisation
prend de l'ampleur. Et deux, il y a une
forme de baisse de la
professionnalisation puisque quand un
service croit beaucoup, ses effectifs
croient et en proportion l'expérience
moyenne d'une équipe va diminuer. Et ce
qu'on avait à la fin de la guerre froide
où il y avait beaucoup de gens qui
avaient fait toute leur carrière dans le
renseignement, on avait des équipes
entières qui avaient 10, 15, 20 ans
d'expérience du renseignement en France,
aux États-Unis, en Grande-Bretagne,
partout. Aujourd'hui, dans les pays
occidentaux, France comprise, on se
retrouve avec des tas de services. Vous
avez des équipes entières où il y a
quelqu'un qui a 10 15 ans d'expérience
et derrière lui euh toute une équipe de
jeunes qui ont 1 an, 2 ans, 3 ans, 4 ans
d'expérience. Et ça c'est un défi, peut
pas dire que ce soit une lacune, mais
c'est un défi que connaissent tous les
services. Et ça explique pourquoi
aujourd'hui le temps joue pour nous.
Parce que après les augmentations
d'effectifs qu'on a connu suite aux
attentats du Bataclan, il a fallu
d'abord créer les concours
administratifs, recruter les gens, faire
les enquêtes de sécurité, les former et
avant qu'ils acquièrent suffisamment
d'expérience pour être vraiment
opérationnel, et ben vous voyez, on a
passé 5 ans et on est aujourd'hui
au-delà de cette période de 5 ans et je
pense que les résultats vont commencer à
se voir. En tout cas, je l'espère.
Comment vous expliquez qu'ils aient pas
vu venir les révolutions arabes ?
C'était très difficile, je pense, à à
voir pour deux raisons. Euh, d'abord
parce
tout parce que je crois que on ne
cherche que ce qu'on trouve en matière
de renseignement. Donc, c'est à un
moment donné où un service n'est pas
orienté sur un sujet, il y a pas
véritablement de raison qu'il le voit.
Parce que contrairement à ce qu'on
imagine, si on lui pose pas de
questions, le service va faire un peu de
prospective, il va faire remonter des
choses, mais en réalité, il va pas
accorder tous ses moyens pour essayer
d'eler une évolution de de tendance. Euh
la deuxième chose, c'est que ces
révolutions arabes, c'est quand même un
mix entre les frustrations, les
insatisfactions qu'on pouvait observer
depuis une dizaine d'années dans le
monde arabe. Si on prend l'exemple de la
Tunisie,
depuis le début du 21e siècle jusqu'à
2011, on voit quasiment des révoltes
tous les ans en Tunisie. La révolte des
du pain, la révolte des ouvriers de
Toer. Donc pourquoi est-ce qu'en 20101
la révolte du pain, c'est pas en Égypte
? Je crois que de vous avez peut-être
raison, mais il me semble qu'il y en a
une aussi euh en Tunisie. Et en 2011,
toutes ces toutes ces révoltes qu'on
voyait quasiment se produire tous les
ans basculent.
Et ce qu'on a ce qu'on n'a pas décelé,
ce qu'on à l'époque, c'est que les
organisations américaines et non pas les
services, beaucoup de gens ont attribué
un certain nombre de responsabilités de
service.
Corosité entre organisation. Alors, ce
que j'appelle c'est les fondations liées
au partis politiques, hein, le
Nationalment for Democracy et toutes les
toutes les je dirais la constellation
d'ONG qui ont finalement pris le relais
des services en matière de politique
étrangère qui était financé par le
département d'État et qui appliquait
toutes les théories des révolutions
oranges. Et bien, elles se sont
intégrées dans le tissu social
principalement au Maghreb et et au
Prochrient. Et en 2011, elle leur ont
apporté un soutien direct. Ce qui fait
que toutes ces révoltes ou ces
révolutions qui étaient limitées par
voie de fait parce qu'elle n'était pas
soutenue par l'étranger, et bien cette
année-là, elles ont toutes basculé.
Alors,
en train de me dire que
certaines
réminiscence du gouvernement américain a
stimulé les révolutions arabes.
Oui, ils ont exploité une tendance.
Alors, il y a pas une organisation
planifiée derrière. Et si mes souvenirs
sont on n pas chopé, je demande à me
faire fact checker par la communauté. On
n pas chopé un fils d'ambassadeur en
Égypte qui avait le bon petit kit du
révolutionnaire avec de l'argent
liquide, des CD, des choses comme ça ?
Je me souviens pas de ce cas-là, mais ce
que je peux vous dire, c'est que nous
avons monté nous en 2011 un groupe
francophone international d'évaluation
de la situation dans les conflit arabe.
Il y avait dans ce groupe le préfet Yve
Bonet, l'ancien patron de la DST,
Anne-Marie Lisin qui est décédé à
quelques temps, qui était la présidente
du Sénat Belgique. Il y avait Saida
Benabilè qui est une ancienne sénatrice
algérienne et qui est aujourd'hui
présidente du croissant rouge algérien
et quelques autres experts. Donc un un
véritable
melting pot d'individus avec des points
de vue et des cultures différentes. Ce
que nous avons observé en échange en
allant sur place et en échangeant, c'est
que tous les acteurs des révolutions
arabes, les leaders, les leaders
notamment les ceux qui intervenaient sur
internet, les les blogueurs, on les
retrouve à partir de 2002, depuis 2002
dans toute une série de réunions
organisées ou par le département d'État
ou par des ONG américaines dans
lesquelles on commence à leur apprendre
comment prendre la parole en public,
comment faire de la contestation non
violente, comment utiliser les réseaux
sociaux pour mobiliser et je ne dirais
pas qu'il y a une stratégie américaine.
se serait aller voir trop loin. Quand on
connaît l'histoire et les dessous de
l'histoire en matière de renseignement,
les aléas et les conjonctures sont très
nombreuses. Mais il est indéniable que
ça joue un rôle. Et puis surtout, je
voudrais insister sur deux points
auxquels on n'a pas accordé assez
d'importance. En Tunisie comme en
Égypte, la semaine précéd événements à
chaque fois le chef d'étatmajor
part à Washington et là en discussion
avec les Américains, on lui dit "S'il y
a une révolte, vous n'intervenez pas."
Et à partir du moment où l'armée
n'intervient pas, tout ce mouvement
populaire qui se met en place et bien
devient une déferlante et on finalement
on ne fait que permettre la réalisation
de quelque chose qui correspond à des
vraies frustrations de la population
locale, de vraies, je dirais de de
vraies volontés, d'aspiration à la
démocratie de changer le système. Mais
ce qui est très astucieux, c'est qu'on
va orienter ça dans un certain sens. Et
donc finalement toutes ces révolutions
ont été supprimées et ceux qui les ont
lancé n'en ont jamais été euh n'en ont
jamais comment dire eu le bénéfice. Les
orienter dans un certain sens mais à
quel dessin ?
Dès le début, on mesurait bien d'une
certaine façon la crainne qu'avaient les
Américains de la plantation chinoise
dans ces zones pétrolières, notamment en
Libye. Euh, il il y avait il y avait a
priori pour moi, il y avait deux choses.
Il y a eu un accord indéniable entre les
frères musulmans et les États-Unis.
Pourquoi ? Parce que les frères
musulmans sont internationalistes.
Pour eux, la patrie est une pourriture.
Donc c'est parfait, ça gomme toutes les
frontières. Donc y compris en terme de
commerce pour les Américains sont des
alliés très importants. Deux les frères
musulmans sont contre les formes de
syndicalisme et le droit du travail donc
ça les enrangeait beaucoup. 3 ils
avaient un accord de dupe avec les
frères musulmans en leur disant vous
reconnaissez Israël, vous faites vous
prenez un certain nombre de de positions
qui montrent que vous êtes des
islamistes modérés et donc on va on va
travailler avec vous. Et bien sûr les
frères musulmans ont répondu aux
Américains ce qu'il voulaient entendre.
Euh le 4e point, c'est que pour les
Américains, soutenir les frères
musulmans, c'était soutenir des des
islamistes modérés en pensant qu'ils
pourraient s'allier avec eux pour lutter
contre contre Da. Donc on voit à la fois
l'extrait une véritable stratégie
d'apprentis sorcier construite côté
américain. Euh j'oublie le 5è qui est
vous donnerez bien sûr la priorité aux
entreprises américaines dès que vous
serez au pouvoir dans l'ensemble de ces
pays-là. Donc une véritable stratégie
américaine un peu apprentiorcier, en
même temps en phase 2 des frères
musulmans qui sont euh beaucoup plus
astucieux qui leur disent ce qu'ils
veulent entendre et qui essayent de
récupérer là aussi des révolutions dont
ils ne sont pas à l'origine et qu'ils
ont beaucoup mieux réussi à contrôler en
tout cas dans un premier temps que euh
les populations locales qui en étaient à
l'origine.
Vous vous m'avez pas cité sur sur le
terreau fertile
de de ces révolutions, l'augmentation du
coût énergétique. Euh à la même époque,
on voyait le le baril de pétrole péter
des records jusqu'à 147 90 le baril.
Nous, on était sur une prospective de de
on avait vraiment un œil quand je dis
nous c'est notre bande de copains pour
pour surveiller parce que tout est lié à
la consommation énergétique.
Comment vous expliquez qu'il y a pas
au sein des services de renseignement
français des gens qui qui échangent des
des prospectives ? Par exemple, s'il y
en a un qui bosse sur l'énergie, il va
voir son copain qui travaille dans la
ceinture méditerranéenne, il dit
"Écoute, le prix du baril de pétrole là,
vous inquiétez pas, les émeutes du pain
en Égypte, c'est corrélé au prix du
baril de pétrole. Ça peut ça peut faire
un un climat très explosif. C'est parce
que les services de renseignement sont
cloisonnés, sont prétentieux. C'estàd
que les les les gouvernements ou le le
parti politique
en place ne donne pas les bons ordres
parce que celui qui a été mis à la tête
du service de renseignement en question,
c'est simplement, je vais dire
l'extension du gouvernement. Un pentin
c'est quoi un pentin sans manquer de
respect d'ailleurs au pentin ? Non, il y
a plusieurs choses. Je dois avouer que
même euh même dans notre équipe, le les
questions énergétiques n'étaient pas
ressorties comme une comme un élément
majeur. On voyait la tentative de
positionnement des Américains pour
empêcher les Chinois d'accéder aux
ressources énergétiques du proche et du
Moyen-Orient pour limiter leur
développement économique et le danger
qui pourrait représenter à terme. Ça
c'était indignable. Sur le reste, sur
pourquoi est-ce que les services de
renseignement ne voient pas ça ?
D'abord, je n'y je n'y suis plus. Après
que ce type
toujours
que ce type de discussion a lieu en
l'interne, évidemment c'est possible. Il
y a des gens intelligents, il y a des
gens visionnaires comme il y a des gens
d'une médiocrité comme on les trouve
dans toutes les administrations. Mais
est-ce que ces réflexions là remontent
dans le cadre de réunion stratégique et
remontent jusqu'à la direction pu à
l'Élysée ? Honnêtement, c'est assez
rare. C'est assez rare. Mais en
n'oublions pas une chose, faire du
renseignement, c'est pas faire de la
prospective,
c'est faire remonter simplement du
renseignement brut.
Non, pas nécessairement du renseignement
brut, mais idéalement l'activité de
renseignement c'est une activité de
service au centre tertière du terme.
C'estd que si le gouvernement n'a pas
une stratégie et ne vous oriente pas en
vous posant des questions, c'est ce
qu'on a connu pendant des années, moi je
me souviens jusque des années 80 90, les
services de renseignement étaient dans
si je prends une expression business
était dans des logiques push. Ils
essayaient de se poser la question
qu'est-ce qu'intéresse le gouvernement,
il trouver de l'information, il est
remontait aux autorités et parfois les
autor souvent les autorités disaient ce
que nous envoie la DGSE ne nous
intéresse pas. Pourquoi ? Parce qu'il
n'y avait pas de formulation de besoins
de la part des autorités. Et ça c'est
dans dans la règle de fonctionnement du
renseignement. Si on prend l'exemple
britannique où les choses fonctionnent
mieux que chez nous, euh le foreign
Office qui pilote à la fois
l'intelligence service, donc le SIS et
le JCHQ, fait une réunion stratégique en
chaque début d'année, parfois plus
souvent leur disant voilà ma politique
étrangère officielle cette année, elle
est de telle nature, ma politique
occulte, elle va être de telle nature et
je vous demande d'écouter les Français,
de faire en sorte de les mettre dehors
sur les contrats d'armement en Inde. On
leur donne des vrais objectifs et des
vraies missions, mais on leur demande
pas de réfléchir sur l'évolution de la
sécurité nationale britannique à
l'horizon 2020. C'est pareil chez nous.
Donc n'attendons pas des services, des
choses pour lesquelles ils ne sont pas
faites. Il y a des des centres d'analyse
et de prévision au qu d'ors il y a des
film tank, il y a euh la direction euh
des relations internationales, ministère
défense qui normalement sont chargés de
ça.
Effectivement, est-ce que la réflexion
va très loin ? Euh en tout cas sur les
sur les sur les révolutions arabes, nous
avons étudié la manière dont ça se
passait. Nous n'avons pas cherché à
analyser les raisons pour lesquelles euh
le système technocratique français ne
l'avait pas nécessairement vu venir.
Et donc là, si je vous si je comprends
bien euh euh je vais résumer le
trivialement pour nos auditeurs. Les
services de renseignement sont
simplement des chiens pisteurs qu'on
envoie sur une cible. Mais si le
chasseur est mauvais, le chien ne
ramènera rien.
Oui. Alors, je vais prendre
pédagogiquement une deuxième une autre
comparaison. La comparaison qui est
entre l'av l'aviation de chasse et
l'aviation d'attaque. L'aviation de
chasse, c'est le contre-espionnage. Vous
faites décoller vos avions, ils ont une
mission permanente, ils doivent protéger
l'espace aérien français. Vous n'avez
pas besoin de les orienter toutes les
semaines. Ils savent qu'ils doivent
abattre tous les avions qui arrivent.
J'ai envie de dire le métier n'est pas
facile mais le contexte est facile. Le
le renseignement c'est l'aviation de
bombardement. Vous pouvez pas faire
décoller un avion sans lui avoir donné
l'objectif, sans lu sans qu'il ait les
coordonnées GPS, sans qu'il ait choisi
le type de bombe qui va avoir sous la
carlingue parce que si s'il vise un
objet bétonné ou une infrastructure
civile, il va pas emmener le même type
de monde. Donc on a trop tendance à
parler des services de renseignement de
manière globale. Il y a des services de
sécurité, il y a des services spéciaux,
il y a des services de renseignement et
notamment en matière de service de
renseignement, s'ils ne sont pas
orientés, ils ne peuvent pas donner leur
pleine
leur pleine efficacité. Je vais juste
vous citer une anecdote historique qui
est très amusante que je tiens de
Constantin Melnck. Lorsque De Gaul
revient au pouvoir en 58, il discuta
avec le général Grossin qui était le le
chef du SDEC à l'époque et il demande à
Grossin "Mon général, à quoi vous servez
?" En substance, Grossin lui dit euh
"Mon général également, euh je suis là
pour faire tout ce qui vous semblera bon
en fonction des directives que vous me
donnerez." Et De Gaulle lui dit deux
choses au début. Il dit "Écoutez, je
vous donne deux objectifs. Vous
renversez Franco et vous annexez la
Wallonie.
Si on s'en était arrêté là, il y avait
un véritable objectif stratégique que le
chef d'état donne à son patron de
service et après le patron de service se
débrouille pendant de 3 ans pour
atteindre les objectifs. Bon, il se
trouve qu'au cours de la conversation
après le Gaul lui a dit "Vous espionnez
les États-Unis, on est sorti avec un
catalogue à la préver qui n'était plus
tenable pour pour le patron d'USDEC."
Mais sur la partie renseignement
extérieur, j'insiste bien, l'orientation
est quelque chose d'essentiel.
Donc de la prospective,
non de la prospective métier, pas de la
prospective stratégique. Le rôle d'un
service, c'est pas de décrire ce que
sera l'évolution de l'humanité dans les
années qui viennent. Il y a que la CIA
qui fait ça dans son livre annuel. Son
but c'est sa réflexion doit s'intégrer.
En France, on le comprend bien, on fait
le livre blanc. Alors, on peut dire que
le livre blanc est bien fait ou mal
fait, mais on le jeu, les services, il
participent à côté de personnes qui
réfléchissent au ministère de la
défense, aux affaires étrangères. Donc
là effectivement, il y a il y a il y a
un ensemble où les services apportent
des choses très utiles, mais ce n'est
pas au service seul d'essayer de définir
le futur. Ça n'a ça n'a pas et je pense
que si on fait ça, on les utilise mal.
Revenons à nos cellules de prospective,
par exemple celle du Kedoret qui n'a pas
vu voir venir les révolutions arabes.
Est-ce que ces gens-là sont remplacés
quand il quand ils se prennent des murs
ou quand ils sont totalement bornes et
aveugles ou simplement ils continuent le
pantouflage ou il continue d'être un
petit peu planqué pour certaines
cellules de prospective à à continuer de
déambuler comme des fantômes, à écrire
des papiers qui ne seront jamais lus
financer avec nos impôts.
Oui. Vous dressez un tableau très noir
parce que OK d'Orscé comme ailleurs, ce
sont des administrations avec en partie
des des gens compétents comme on le
disait tout à l'heure et puis aussi des
rapports de force. Vous avez des
courants, des chapelles internes. Et
donc quand on voit un résultat d'une
d'une politique ou d'une d'une étude,
c'est aussi le résultat de confrontation
de point de vue et parfois de
confrontation de points de vue politique
sur un pays. Vous avez OK d'orer des
prochinois et des antiichinois. Vous
donc euh si on ne connaît pas bien la
technure, on narrive pas toujours à
comment dire à à détecter comme comment
la prise de décision s'est faite.
Maintenant, c'est vrai qu'il y a eu un
moment où le le centanisme de prévision
avait une véritable un véritable rôle
euh à la fois avec un groupe d'experts
et en plus financer une série d'études
qu'il commandaaient au Fingtong pour
essayer de de dégager un point de vue.
Il fut un temps avant la réforme PIC de
1995 où le secrétat général de défense
nationale avait ce rôle-là. Aujourd'hui,
on s'est appauvri parce qu' à ma
connaissance, il y a plus grand monde au
quedé. Le SGDSN ne joue plus ce rôle-là.
Euh et donc ceci dit, il est tellement
difficile de de dégager des lignes de
force pour l'avenir aujourd'hui que à
part le travail sur le livre blanc,
personne ne le fait. Je termine sur un
point. Les Américains qui sont assez
critiques envers la CIA ont tendance à
dire et d'ailleurs c'est assez vrai, la
CIA a prévu 50 des 20 dernières crises.
Ça vous montre que si on on met les les
les services trop dans une situation
d'analyse et de prospective, évidemment
parfois par des formations
professionnelles, à force de ne
travailler que sur des sujets qui sont
liés au crime, à la drogue et donc en
travaillant que sur des organisations
fermées, on a tendance à prévoir le pire
ou à créer le pire.
pré prévoir le pire déjà on n pas vu de
certaines institutions américaines fumer
de du moins armé des groupes islamistes
pour les prendre la main dans le sac
c'est ça s'est fait mais en règle
générale dans nos démocraties
occidentales les dérives des services
sont extrêmement limitées elles sont
infiniment plus limitées que les dérives
du politiqu
1985 l'affaire Greenpeace c'est un
mauvais ordre le service action décide
de le faire. Mais c'est c'est avant tout
un ordre politique. Après, il est
toujours facile pour les politiques de
se défausser sur les services. L'affaire
Ben Barca n'est absolument pas une
affaire commandé commandité par les
services. On l'a attribué au SDEC. C'est
à part dans des pays à un moment donné
comme l'Argentine, l'Uruguay où les
services s'autonomisaient et faisaient
leur propre politique. C'est très rare.
Alors, c'est différent dans le casadre
des États-Unis. Pourquoi ? Parce que à
la différence de du BND, de la DGSE ou
du ou du SIS, la CIA est un acteur de la
politique étrangère. c'est qu'il se
retrouve autour de la table avec le
State Department, avec euh avec le DHS,
avec le Pentagone et ils sont rattachés
directement au président et ils peuvent
tenter par leurs actions d'influer et de
provoquer un certain nombre de choses.
Mais en grande partie, ils sont quand
même euh aux ordres et j'irai plus loin,
aujourd'hui la C a probablement, en tout
cas jusqu'il y a il y a quelques années,
la C avait plus de mal à dissimuler des
opérations clandestines au Congrès que
le Pentagone.
le Patagone pouvait créer des black
units que personne ne soupçonnait alors
que la CIA était quand même sous l'effet
de enfin du contrôle parlementaire des
des commissions d'Aversite et alors avec
la lutte contre le terrorisme, ils ont
repris certaines comment dire certaines
libertés. Quand on parle d'erreur de nos
amis américains qui en font comme tout
le monde, je crois qu'il faut il faut
rappeler une chose. À la fin de la
guerre froide, plus de 30 % des cadres
de la CIA et de la NSA considérant que
leur expertise en matière de lutte
contre les soviétiques, contre les
services soviétiques et leurs alliés,
leur maîtrise des langues des pays
d'Europe de l'Est n'avaient aucun
avenir. Ils ont quitté les services de
renseignement. Ils sont partis
d'ailleurs la naissance de
l'intelligence économique américaine
vient de là parce que ils ont apporté un
véritable savoir-faire d'opérateurs
clandestin dans les sociétés privées.
Mais ça veut donc dire que petit à petit
des organisations majeures ont perdu 30
% de leurs effectifs les plus efficaces
et surtout ça s'est produit à un moment
donné où les générations changaient.
jusqu'à la fin de la guerre forne, on
avait essentiellement des gens qui
arrivaient de la côte est, donc plutôt
de culture européenne venant de Boston,
de la Nouvelle Angleterre. Et assez
rapidement, en même temps que les
effectifs ont connu une déflation, ils
ont été remplacés par des gens arrivant
de Californie, du Texas avec le avec un
niveau d'éducation plus faible, un
niveau de connaissance du monde étranger
plus faible pour lesquels arabe égal
terroristes et donc tout ça fait que le
niveau de ces services là a également
baissé. Donc les explications sont
toujours un peu plus complexes qui n'y
paraît extérieurement. Est-ce que vous
connaissez la théorie des des
bayonnettes intelligentes ?
Alors, je je sais ce que Napoléon disait
des bayonnettes, mais je ne connais pas
la théorie des bayonnettes
intelligentes.
On va laisser notre communauté chercher.
Revenons sur la NSA,
l'affaire snow. Ouais.
Euh, revenons sur la politique de la
France qui lui refuse l'asile. Revenons
sur la politique de la France concernant
Assange.
Assange qui a son fils en France, je
crois bien. Est-ce que la France est
devenue totalement le vassal américain ?
Est-ce que la France craint tellement le
l'aigle américain que le coq français en
a perdu ses plumes ?
Alors, plusieurs questions, plusieurs
réponses de ma part. Premier aspect,
est-ce que nous sommes redevenus non pas
le vassal mais les auxiliaires des
Américains ? Oui, je suis régulièrement
à l'étranger et a l'année dernière au
cours d'une réunion au Moyen-Orient, un
de mes interlocuteurs me dit "Hey,
France is back." Je dis "Comment ça la
France est pas de retour ?" Il me dit
"Non, la France est de retour dans le
rang. Finalement, vous êtes depuis
quelques années revenu dans le rang.
Vous êtes comme les Allemands, comme les
Anglais, comme les Italiens, vous êtes
revenus des auxiliaires américains. Ça
fait mal, mais je dois concéder que
c'est vrai.
Euh alors, deux choses à cela. Est-ce
que l'on a peur des Américains ou est-ce
que l'on croit ou est-ce qu'on est gagné
à l'idéologie américaine ? Je pense
qu'il y a vraiment les deux.
Indéblement, nos élites aujourd'hui sont
de plus en plus gagné aux idéaux
américains et notamment aux idéos
néoconservateurs. Alors à mon sens pour
deux raisons. Certains se disent c'est
le sens de l'histoire, on est devenu
petit, on peut pas s'opposer aux
Américains. Donc j'ai presque envie de
dire retournons notre veste parmi les
premiers pour être sûr d'en tirer des
bénéfices.
Et puis d'autres se disent et notamment
une partie de des élites de gauche
française qui ont été très tiermondistes
à un moment donné et qui se rend compte
que le tiersmonde ça ne marche pas et
qui ont fait presque sur un plan
idéalgique un virage à 180° qui sont
aujourd'hui les premiers critiques de ce
qui se passe dans le TIM et qui par
presque de manière mécanique sont
devenus à partager des des des idéos
néoconservateurs. Donc on a à la fois
des mercenaires qui changent leur veste.
On l'a vu dans l'affaire Alstom. Il faut
être extrêmement clair. C'est une
trahison des élites qui mériterait des
procès en cascade. Et de l'autre côté,
on a des gens qui sont convaincus que
finalement euh il y a rien à tirer de
d'un certain nombre de pays que les que
le monde islamique ne réussit pas et
qu'il faut se comporter de cette
façon-là avec eux. Ben résultat, ça fait
déjà deux de moitiés enfin en tout cas
deux parties de nos élites qui ramenent
dans le même sens que ce qui se passe à
Washington.
J'ai envie d'ajouter que la la récente
réaction du président Macron au moment
du G7 avec l'invitation
avec les Russes,
le rapprochement avec les Russes et et
la venue de du premier ministre de
pardon du ministre d'affaires étrangères
iranien à mon sens n'est pas une
initiative française.
On le présente comme un ultime sursaut
de notre politique étrangère avec ce qui
s'est passé au Quédor mais je n'imagine
pas un instant
la France et Emmanuel Macron prendre
cette décision là sans en avoir informé
préalablement les Américains. J'irai
même plus loin. Hier, John Pulton a été
débarqué et c'est une excellente chose
qui
le conseiller à la sécurité nationale de
Donald Trump qui est le dernier
néoconservateur encore qui était présent
dans dans l'appareil dans la tech dans
la technure américaine. John Bolton a
probablement fait ce qu'a essayé de
faire Donald Rumsfeld dans son temps,
c'est-à-dire utiliser le Pentagone pour
déclencher une guerre sans en informer
le président et le mettre devant le fait
accompli. Et c'est pour ça que notamment
il a été lâché par Pompeo, le le patron
du département d'État. Euh Bolton était
totalement fou. Euh il voulait
déclencher la guerre contre l'Iran, il
était anti Poutine et en plus il voulait
envoyer les portes-avions américains en
raison de ce qui se passe à Hong Kong.
N'oublions pas que Trump était pas
antirusse. Seulement Trump ne peut pas
prendre la décision tout seul de se
rapprocher de la Russie. Il a besoin
d'un éclaireur. Un éclaireur qui refasse
la jonction. Regardez les alors il y a
deux choses qui sont importantes.
Regardez les images de la conivance
entre Trump et Macron au dernier G7.
Elles sont très intéressantes.
Deuxième chose, on a ressorti sur la
télévision américaine hier une phrase de
Trump au G7 qui n'était pas sortie au
moment du G7. Trump dit il vaut mieux
que Poutine soit dans l'attente qu'à
l'extérieur. Donc j'ai mets de forts
doutes sur la réelle autonomie française
et je me réjouis de cette ce changement
de de politique mais je j'imtes sur la
réelle autonomie française. Mais
peut-être que je me trompe.
À la semaine des ambassadeurs,
d'ailleurs, on les remercie d'avoir
fermé toutes les invitations publiques.
Macron a a
demandé à à ses chiens de garde, si je
peux les appeler comme ça, de d'être
plus cool
avec le le rapprochement russe, avec la
la diplomatie russe et des choses comme
ça. Est-ce que vous pensez que nous nous
sommes vérôés par des néoconservateurs
qui vivent dans un ancien temps et qui
tiennent encore les institutions
françaises et qui pourraient empêcher
l'ordre du président ? Non, je ne pense
pas qu'il ait des freins et des comment
dire et des blocages et des retards.
Oui, bien sûr. Non, honnêtement, quel
que soit les défauts que nous pouvons
avoir au niveau national ou
administration,
les gens quand même fonctionnent
correctement. Tout n'est pas
satisfaisant mais imaginez
des structures essayant de saboter
le le pouvoir, les les directives du
président. Non, ce sont plus des
affrontements. Il y a des négociations,
il y a des tentatives, il y a des
retards, mais je n'y crois pas. Tout le
monde n'est pas antirusse au qu d'orsé
ni dans les armées. Le la vraie
question, c'est est-ce que ça n'arrive
pas trop tard ? parce qu'aujourd parce
que finalement les Américains et
notamment les équipes de la de la CIA
ont fini par provoquer ce qu'elle disait
il y a quelques années qui était faux,
vu que nous avons bafoué un certain
nombre d'accords euros et écrits qui
avaient été euh signés ou en tout cas
euh comment dire évoqué avec les Russes
à la fin de la guerre froide, euh
pendant longtemps, les Russes ont laissé
faire et au bout d'un moment, ils se
sont à leur tour radicalisés.
C'estàd que ils se sont remis à faire de
manière massive de l'espionnage contre
l'Occident. se sont remis à faire les
cyberattaques. C'est une réalité
seulement ces cyberattaques, ces espion
massifs, il faut savoir que nous sommes
en partie responsable de l'avoir
provoqué par l'attitude que nous avons
vis-à-vis des Russes. Alors Poutine
n'est pas un saint, c'est un c'est un
bon officier de renseignement au
demeurant, mais il finalement il a bâti
d'une part sa popularité sur son
opposition à l'Occident depuis quelques
temps en disant "Ne peux pas faire
confiance à ces gens-là." Il y a un vrai
mépris des Européens en disant vous êtes
des auxiliaires, des Américains, vous
n'avez plus d'autonomie et la France a
beaucoup chuté notamment dans leur dans
leur estime. Euh je pense que et je
souhaite que les relations s'améliorent,
mais on risque de se regarder enin de
faillance parce que on a creusé le
fossé. L'air de rien,
c'est un jeu dangereux de pas respecter
sa parole avec les Russes,
avec tout le monde. C'est un jeu
extrêmement dangereux.
Est-ce que Est-ce que la parole
diplomatique française n'est pas devenue
une parole de d'une puissance de moyenne
impuissance ?
Elle a perdu de son poids mais en raison
de notre merveilleuse histoire, de cet
héritage historique, de ce qui s'est
passé, jadis, elle garde encore quelque
chose.
Il faut se battre pour la garder
davantage, mais elle garde encore
quelque chose. On a toujours ce bénéfice
de de de de de l'histoire, de la
grandeur, de de du nonalignement qui a
disparu sous Jacques Chirac, hein, parce
que tout ça a commencé après 2003. avec
l'Ir
après après s'être opposé de manière
tout à fait justifiée, intelligente et
même véhément à la politique américaine
dans les mois qui ont suivi, n'oublions
pas que Jack Cherc s'est rendu compte
que ça en tout cas a pris peur et il y a
eu dans l'ombre un virage là aussi à 380
pardon à 180° ça suffit et voilà et donc
on est c'est pas après Chirac c'est dès
dès la présidence Chiraak que ils se
sont dit à tort on est peut-être allé
trop loin donc maintenant on va donner
des gages
Et c'est malheureuse la mécanique
remonte à quelques années déjà.
On reviendra peut-être sur la Russie
après. Je voudrais que qu'on
et on n pas parlé de Snowen.
Allez.
Je défends Snowden.
C'est un lanceur d'alerte absolument
indispensable. Alors je je serai
américain. Je comprends tout à fait que
ce soit un traître en terme juridique
pour quelqu'un qui est dans le
renseignement. Mais en même temps, c'est
quelqu'un, je mets de côté ce son
parcours personnel et ce qui l'a amené à
prendre cette décision qu'il explique
aujourd'hui euh d'une manière peut-être
un peu circonstantiée. Mais Snowden est
supérieurement utile.
Le fait que euh nous n'ayons aucune euh
je dirais assistance procéder à aucune
assistance à son égard, c'est différent
du cas d'assange est quand même quelque
chose d'anormal
he parce que le système américain
devient fou.
Vous vous disiez tout à l'heure, est-ce
qu'on n'est pas avec Geno conservateur ?
Je je pense que notre monde occidental
véhicule un discours qui qui a tendance
à dire le monde a changé, il faut le
regarder différemment. Sauf que beaucoup
des gens qui sont aux affaires
continuent à clamer ça mais en
raisonnant avec les méthodes de avec les
modes de réflexion que même ont gardé de
la guerre froide et ce qui entraîne une
espèce de de de de déséquilibre parfois
de schizophrénie et généralement plus ce
plus les gens disent il faut regarder le
monde différemment plus ils sont coincés
dans un certain nombre d'idées d'idées
reçu et le fait de ne pas mesurer
aujourd'hui que pendant la guerre froide
nous avions d'un côté un système
totalitaire soviétique un des pires que
l'humanité n'est jamais produit avec la
volonté d'exporter la révolution, la
dictature du prolétariat, le soutien à
des mouvements terroristes, le soutien à
des mouvements communistes, les pires
massacres même si les nazis ont fait la
choix, les pires massacres restent
malgré tout les les massacres d'EC
rouge, de Mao et de et de
et de Staline. Et à de l'autre côté,
nous avions les États-Unis qui est une
démocratie extraordinaire. Et en
l'espace de 20 ans, la R la Russie est
loin d'être parfaite, mais elle attend.
Les États-Unis aussi, c'est un peu la
merde en Amérique du Sud, hein.
Mais en tout cas, c'était le le champion
du camp occidental avec un système qui
marchait bien. Et puis en l'espace de 20
de 10 ans après la fin de la guerre
fraude, la Russie qui n'est certes pas
le paradis sur terre a commencé des
expériences démocratiques, à essayer de
se réformer, à donner son indépendance
de manière forcée ou pas forcée à toute
une série de pays, à essayer de revenir
vers nous. Donc, il y a eu une
amélioration. De l'autre côté, les
Américains sont radicalisés. Ils ont
commencé euh à imposer leurs droits
international à peu près partout. Ils
ont commencé à agir de manière unit
latérale. N'oublions pas que c'est pour
la première des démocraties, c'est le
pays qui a légalisé la torture. Nous
avons eu nous cette expérience en
Algérie, on a fait notre coup et les
choses n'étaient pas légalisées au plus
haut niveau du gouvernement. Les
Américains ont fait travailler des
avocats du département de la justice
pour légaliser la torture. Ils ont mis
sur écoute la totalité de leur
population plus la moitié de la terre.
Ils trahissent leurs alliés. Ils
soutiennent les pires régimes qu'il soi
qui sont à l'origine du terrorisme
islamique, l'Arabie Saoudite et le
Qatar. Donc par contre, ils ont été très
très astucieux. Pour avoir longuement
étudié la manière pendant la guerre
froide dont le KGB déstabiliser
l'Occident et gagné la bataille
idéologique, ils l'ont retourné. Ils
l'ont retourné d'abord eux-mêmes et puis
ensuite en activant toutes ces ONG que
l'on évoquait tout à l'heure. Donc
aujourd'hui, on continue à nous
présenter la Russie encore une fois qui
n'est pas le modèle démocratique
parfait. C'est bien évident, il est pas
au niveau de l'Union. La Russie n'est
pas au niveau de l'Union européenne,
mais tout ça dissimule en réalité la
dérive quasi fasciste qui se produit
aujourd'hui aux États-Unis.
On en a de on a multiples de multiples
exemples. 2003, c'est une invasion
illégale de l'Irak. Les Américains bafou
le droit international, hein. La remise
en côte du du GCPO et donc l'accord de
2015 avec l'Iran sur le nucléaire, c'est
les Américains sont en train de bafouer
des accords qu'ils ont signés. Est-ce
que vous voyez des gens aujourd'hui euh
monter au créneau, hurler en disant ce
qui est censé être la première
démocratie du monde et euh le le comment
dire le le pays qui donne le ton et qui
doit donner l'exemple est rentrer dans
une vraie logique de dérive. Pour moi,
c'est une République policière. Le droit
américain permet d'arrêter de manière
quasi euh arbitraire n'importe quel
individu. Deux types du FBI peuvent
arriver sur un campus, dire je monte un
groupe terroriste, attirer trois
étudeurs marocains qui sont là et après
les coffrets en leur disant "Vous
essayie de monter un état terroriste. Où
sommes-nous ?"
Ils peuvent aussi organiser des vols
secrets pour les prisons de la CIA en
Europe.
Non mais c'est on est on est
où ça torture.
Nous pourrions faire une liste, je
crois. avec 17 ou 18 points de
l'ensemble des éléments qui font que
nous ne sommes plus là, si on est un peu
objectif, sur un régime qui répond aux
normes démocratique.
Et je ne suis pas anti-américain par
principe. On a coopéré avec eux pendant
la guerre froide. Je suis ravi que le
camp occidental les emporté contre le
totalitarisme soviétique. Mais les
choses ont changé. Or aujourd'hui,
est-ce que vous voyez que les choses
échangaient en matière de politique à
l'égard de la Russie ? Non. Les
Américains ont besoin de créer un ennemi
pour resserrer les rangs de l'OTAN
autour d'eux et à ce moment-là il il ne
recourés pas à recourir à toutes sortes
de moyens, y compris la falsification
des faits sur la révolution ukrainienne,
sur toute une série de choses pour
noircir le tableau de le tableau de
Poutine qui encore une fois n'est pas un
sain. Nous sommes d'accord.
Vous vous parlez de falsification de la
révolution ukrainienne. En quoi ça a été
falsifié ? Écoutez, je euh d'abord
première chose, la réalité politique de
l'Ukraine euh queles que soient les
aspirations d'une partie de la
population, mérite d'être étudié
historiquement avec avec précision. Euh
250 personnes de la CIA présentent sur
place au moment de la révolution en
soutien du SBU, le service ukrainien.
Bon, avant même finalement que les
premiers combats existent entre la
partie orientale de l'Ukraine et et et
ceux qui adhérent comment dire qui qui
voulaient adérer l'Union européenne.
N'oublions pas que tout ça a a s'est
produit le jour où Yanukovic qui était
certes corrompu mais président élu et je
dirais ni plus ni moins mal élu que ses
prédécesseurs ou il y a élu et élu quand
même. Oui, mais regardez, Timotenko,
tous ces gens-là étaient largement aussi
corrompus que lui et élu dans des
conditions approximativement aussi
discutables. C'est le jour où en tant
que chef d'État, il décide de de signer
un accord avec la Russie plutôt qu'avec
l'Union européenne, que les choses
basculent. Euh n'oublions pas après que
le régime ukrainien a finalement déigné
le droit aux populations de l'est de
l'Ukraine de parler le Russe et de
choisir leur destin. Bon, il y a encore
une fois dire que derrière les forces
spéciales euh les forces spéciales
soviétiques russes pardon jou un rôle.
Nous sommes d'accord. Mais mon seul
propos, c'est de dire la vérité est
quelque part au milieu. Nous avons
systématiquement cherché à noircir un
adversaire euh à des fins politiques.
Euh certes, il n'est pas il n'est pas
euh blanc-ne, si je puis dire, mais euh
on lui attribue des choses qui servent
essentiellement à dissimuler les actions
que nous avons nous-mêmes conduites.
Vous vous parlez de la la vérité qui qui
se trouve au milieu. Comment vous
expliquez que en France c'est c'est très
très difficile de se retrouver au milieu
? Mais d'abord, je ne sais pas si la
vérité est au milieu. Elle est quelque
part peut-être. Euh
vous avez compris ma question ?
Oui.
Euh bah parce queon est malgré tout, je
pense dans ce pays du politiquement
correct.
C'est c'est assez surprenant. Euh nous
sommes à la fois euh un pays dans lequel
il y a énormément de points de vue. Je
vous renvoie à l'excellente interview
d'Emmanuel Todd que vous avez fait il y
a quelques temps. Je crois qu'il faut
aussi lire tous ces ouvrages avec ceux
d'Emmanuel Lebras pour voir la
composition euh euh
je dirais sociologique qu'il décrit très
bien de de de et euh et anthropologique
de la société française. Je fais juste
un aparté. Pourquoi est-ce que
historiquement tous les drames, toutes
les grands épisodes que nous avons connu
en France ont une valeur universelle ?
c'est qu'on retrouve sur notre
territoire tout tous les types
anthropologiques qui sont présents dans
les pays voisins qui eux-mêmes n'ont pas
autant de type anthropologique. Donc
toute lutte sociale, tout conflit
interne en France a obligatoirement une
répercussion mondiale parce que nous
avons en échantillon toute une série de
de de comportements et de et de de type
sociologiqu et donc nous sommes plus
divisés que les autres. Si on regarde
l'histoire de France, quasiment tous les
conflits externes se sont doublés d'un
conflit interne. Bon et donc moi,
j'observe depuis depuis des années,
notamment au Cambodge qui est un pays
que je je connais bien où j'ai
travaillé, euh nous sommes aussi
capables d'exporter cette division.
C'estàd que les problèmes pol
gendarmerie que nous avons en France,
dès que le Cambodge a été libéré de de
l'occupation vietnamienne après à la fin
des années 90, et bien les Français au
lieu d'envoyer uniquement un des deux
corps ont envoyé les deux corps et
aujourd'hui il y a des problèmes polies
gendarmerie au Cowodge. Voilà, on est on
est capable d'être divisé, d'exporter
ça. Mais le paradoxe, c'est que c'est
aussi chez nous qui n des nations parce
qu'il fallait bien unir des gens qui
avaient peu de points commun. Et on a
fini aussi par créer cette espèce de
courant mainstream du politiquement
correct.
Et je dirais que ça ne s'est pas
amélioré. On est pour le coup en plein
dedans aujourd'hui.
Comment on fait pour combattre ça ?
Mais il faut rétablir une forme de
liberté d'expression. ça ça le per
beaucoup de beaucoup de de on a beaucoup
de moyens de le faire aujourd'hui et
votre chaîne en a un des exemples
seulement ce qu'on ne mesure pas c'est
que c'est
beaucoup plus difficile qu'on l'imagine.
Ce que je veux dire à travers ça, c'est
que pour avoir étudié la désinformation
soviétique pendant la guerre froide qui
était d'une efficacité remarquable,
on s'est dit à la fin de la guerre
froide, non seulement la guerre est
terminée et va on est arrivé rapidement
dans la société de l'information, on
dira on se disait il y aurait plus il y
aura plus jamais des informations de
cette nature là. Or en réalité c'est le
contraire. C'estàd que la societé de
l'information internet, les fake news,
les réseaux sociaux, le contrôle des
médias par un certain nombre de de
grands groupes internationaux notamment
américains n'ont fait que décupler cette
désinformation.
Et ce qui se passe, c'est qu'on est dans
une société où on a probablement 10 ou
100 fois plus de moyens d'information
qu'avant, mais il y a probablement 10000
ou 100000 fois plus de fake news
d'avant. Et ce qui manque, c'est le
filtre. Et aujourd'hui, les jeunes
générations et même nos élites, soit
elles n'ont pas le filtre, soit elles
n'ont pas le temps de faire ce travail
de filtrage.
Ou soit elle pousse.
Oui. Soit elles poussent, elles sont
complices. Mais juste un chiffre ou
quelques chiffres qui moi me sidèrent.
La moy la moyenne de la lecture en
France, un livre et demi par an et par
habitant.
La biographie de Nabila.
Oui, ça intègre, je pense, les
biographies de Zidane et les livres de
recettes de cuisine. Un livre et demi
par an et par habitant.
Vous imaginez ? Alors, ben mais je mets
de côté le les difficultés économiques
du secteur de l'édition. Je mets de côté
aussi qu'on peut en partie compenser par
certaines émissions intelligentes la
culture, mais ne serait-ce que le
processus mental qui est généré par la
lecture
est en train de disparaître.
Et nous, on le ravive beaucoup parce que
on a une communauté qui lit beaucoup,
qui nous envoie beaucoup de bouquins et
d'ailleurs on est très fier d'eux.
Chez nous, ça lit beaucoup.
Revenons, revenons à nos moutons. Euh,
encore un petit mot sur Assange.
Oui, Assange est un personnage plus
sulfureux, je auquel je me suis moins
intéressé parce que euh
je me demande s'il y a pas un côté
anarchiste chez lui de mettre le bazar
pour le plaisir de mettre le bazar.
Donc, il a parfois un rôle utile, il a
parfois un rôle un rôle critiquable.
C'est pour moi différent du cas de de
Snowen qui vraiment parce qu'il a par ce
qu'il a révélé par sa démarche a quand
même quand même attiré l'attention sur
sur beaucoup de choses et finalement a
emmené à provoquer une certaine forme d'
comment dire est parvenu à enrayer le
système américain et ça c'est une c'est
une bonne chose même si le système
américain marche pas aussi bien que ça
parce que entre la quantité
d'interception la vitesse à laquelle on
peut les exploiter ce qu'on peut stocker
et ce qu'on en tire le résultat est pas
très positif.
Attendez de voir la les capacités de
l'intelligence artificielle avec tout ce
qui a été stocké.
Oui, très honnêtement, j'attends de voir
parce que regardez bien, ça fait des on
a cet effet de mode tous les 10 ou 20
ans, même si entre entre les différentes
périodes où on a ces cycles d'effet de
mode, l'intelligence artificielle
progresse. C'est indéiablement un bel
outil. Ce ne sont malgré tout que des
algorithmes. Vous
Ouais. Et et qui qui qui pont
l'algorithme ? Quel dessin ? Euh vous
êtes un ancien officier de des services
de renseignement si je me le trompe. Euh
est-ce que vous appelez des lanceurs
d'alerte au sein de des services de
renseignement français à ouvrir leur
gueule s'ils voi passer des choses euh
inacceptables ?
Non. Euh
difficile comme question. Non
non non non. Ce que je vais vous dire
c'est que pour être tout à fait
objectif, je n'étais pas dans les
services de renseignement. J'étais dans
le renseignement naval. Donc j'ai fait
du renseignement mais je n'ai pas
appartenu à un service de renseignement.
C'est important. Euh
non, j'ai mon on a pas de rôle on n pas
avoir de rôle de lanceur d'alerte
d'abord parce que je suis patriote et
sauf s'il y avait une tentative de coup
d'état organisé de l'intérieur, on le
dirait mais je ne souhaite qu'une seule
chose, c'est qu'ils fassent leur travail
le mieux du monde, que ils
s'épanouissent professionnellement dans
ce qu'ils font. C'est ça qui est
essentiel. Euh
après que certains camarades viennent
nous parler et que nous mesurions à la
fois ce qui va et ce qui ne va pas,
c'est tout à fait normal. Mais on n'est
pas naïf. a il y a pas d'organisation
idéale.
Euh on on va on va faire une petite une
petite aparté.
Agent de renseignement, source, officier
de renseignement, honorable contributeur
ou honorable
correspondant
correspondant.
C'est quoi la différence ? Alors,
d'abord, il y a pas d'agent secret dans
les services.
Euh tout tout en terme de vocabulaire,
on c'est vrai qu'on est souvent induit
en erreur par l'expression américaine de
special agent qui sont les le titre que
portent les officiers les de la de du
FBI. Mais ni à la CIA à la NCA, on va
utiliser le terme de case officer. Euh
les anglais utilisent généralement le
terme de un terme similaire ou chief of
station. Et chez nous, on utilise le
terme ou d'officier traitant ou
d'exploitants ou d'officier de
renseignement dans les armées. Le terme
agent secret, c'est à la fois
techniquement et et et étymologiquement
la personne qui agit secrètement pour
vous, c'est-à-dire un individu qui est
ciblé,
approché, enfin donc environné, recruté,
formé pour vous donner de l'information
et qui accepte un donc dirigé et qui
accepte un plan de communication
contraignant.
Donc ça veut dire qu'on un agent et
quelqu'un qu'on va si demain je donne un
exemple tout à fait tout à fait exact.
Alors Ren je sais pas si vous avez j'ai
vu son interview sur votre ch
c'est un agent de la DGSE.
Écoutez je je n'ai pas regardé la TT de
son interview pour une question de
temps. Son statut me semble un peu
comment dire un petit peu trouble.
trouble, c'est je je ne je le mettre
dans une case ou une autre, mais je vais
vous citer une anecdote qui à mon avis
en matière de pédagogie est plus
intéressante. Lorsque Valérie
Giscardestin arrive au pouvoir en 1974,
euh il convoque le patron euh du service
qui était euh Alexandre de Marangche et
il lui dit une chose qui est assez
intéressante en lui disant "Les
négociations du GAT vont avoir lieu sous
peu. Est-ce que nous avons une source
dans au département du commerce
américain
Bon, à ce moment-là, bien sûr, ce qui
est intéressant, c'est que le patron du
service dit "Mais monsieur le président,
si vous voulez ça, il aurait fallu poser
la question 2 ans avant, le temps que
justement on identifie ce qu'on appelle
une structure utile." Qu'est-ce que
c'est que le département du commerce ?
Où est le bureau qui s'occupe des
négociations du GAT ? Combien sont-ils ?
2 3 8 10 qu'on les étudie les uns après
les autres, qu'on se dise "Ah, il y en a
un qui a une faiblesse, soit il est
problème d'argent, soit il est problèmes
sexuels, soit qu'à ce moment-là ayant
fait son environnement, on voit si on
peut l'approcher, qu'on décide sur quel
levier on va jouer, comment on va le
manipuler, qu'une fois que si ces
choses-là arrivent à se faire,
qu'ensuite on le forme, hein, pour qu'il
nous transmet des documents, qu'il fasse
un centre de photographie et qu'on mette
en place avec lui un plan de
communication pour que les documents qui
nous transmettent ne soient jamais
décelés." Bon, c'est beaucoup plus qu'un
indique de police
avec qui on va alors je dis les indiques
de police sont hautement utiles
également mais la notion d'agent c'est
ça c'est quel et en plus pour terminer
s'il est pris l'agent n'a pas la
couverture diplomatique il est pendu
fusillé ou ou emprisonné alors que
l'officier traitant qui travaille depuis
d'ambassade ou qui vient pour des
émissions de courte durée lui bénéficie
ou de passeport diplomatique ou d'un
passeport de service.
Euh on reviendra sur ces ces petites
questions de source, de taupe euh et
ainsi de suite, mais je voudrais je
voudrais qu'on prenne un peu de temps
sur l'Arabie Saoudite, le Qatar et la
schizophrénie diplomatique française de
traiter avec ces gens-là. Ouais. euh en
particulier l'Arabie Saoudite qui
découpe les gens des journalistes dans
leur propre ambassade. Ils sont fait
avoir par les services de renseignement
turc qui avaient monitoré l'intégralité
de l'ambassade. Euh hier, j'ai lu euh
les les le compte-rendu de certaines
voix qui étaient dans l'ambassade.
Il y a un mec qui dit "Bon ben, j'ai pas
l'habitude de travailler sur des corps
chauds.
D'habitude, je mets mon casque, je bois
un petit peu de thé et tout va bien se
passer.
Comment vous expliquez
qu'on parle encore avec ces gens-là ?
que ces gens-là ne soient pas plus
secoués par le la communauté
internationale ?
Je veux bien qu'on ait des contrats
hauteur de 10 milliards chaque année et
tout tout va bien. Mais est-ce que notre
parole diplomatique a aussi perdu toute
dignité ?
Je pense que c'est pas une question
dignité de parole diplomatique. Pour
moi, il y a il y a deux raisons. Vous en
avez évoqué une, c'est l'argent.
l'argent qu'elle soit sur des grands
contrats, sur du sur des finances sur
des investissements chez nous, sur
parfois du financement de parti ou
d'individus, il faut être très clair. La
deuxième chose, c'est que ce sont des
ailers des Américains.
À partir du moment où les Américains les
ont choisis, les ont absus d'un certain
nombre de choses et que les Américains
les protègent,
je ne pense pas que nous ayons des
hommes politiques suffisamment courageux
pour prendre la décision. Quand bien
même il sera assez courageux pour
prendre la décision, nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui les moyens de nous protéger
d'une éventuelle riposte américaine.
C'estd qu'il faudrait aujourd'hui que
nous mettions en place quelque chose en
disant dans 5 ans, nous allons grompre
nos relations avec la rugby saoudite et
le Qatar. Nous avons à craindre
peut-être des réactions américaines et
qu'à ce moment-là euh nous ayons nous
soyons en avance de phase d'une certaine
façon. Mais aujourd'hui, c'est c'est
impossible. Alors, je je j'ajoute à cela
qui en plus de l'enfumage, hein, vous
allez trouver un certain nombre de
personnes qui coopèrent avec les
services saoudiens et Qatarie qui
luttent contre l'islam radical. Mais il
y en a mais bien sûr parce qu'il luttent
contre ce le type d'islam radical qui
porte à tête à leur pouvoir.
Et donc, vous trouvez des gens plein de
bonne foi dans les services français,
étrangers qui vous disent "Non, non, les
Saoudiens lutent contre l'islam
radical." Bon, euh, ça ne veut
strictement rien dire. Non, c'est c'est
pour moi une des plus grandes
aberrations euh actuelles. Euh j'ai
envie de dire c'est comme euh c'est
comme si on essayait de lutter contre la
montée d'un nazisme en France en étant
allié à l'Allemagne,
c'est vraiment de ce niveau-là. Euh on
est quand même dans un cas de figure
extraordinaire. les le sunisme
représente 90 % de l'islam
et le whabisme représente à peine 10 %
du sunisme. C'estàd qu'en gros, on est à
entre 8 et 9 % du monde musulman qui est
à l'origine du bazar actuel.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'en 2003 les
Américains n'ont pas envahi Riad de A
plutôt que d'aller à Bagdad ? Alors, je
ne dis pas que cétait facile et que les
conséquences n'auraient pas été
dramatiques, mais honnêtement, on marche
sur la tête.
On est sur des régimes alors Pierre
connaît ça qui est un ami en parle
encore mieux que moi. On est sur régime
misogy sectaire obscurantiste,
archaïque, mais c'est c'est absolument
bien. Comment nous une démocratie
occidentale pv pouvons-nous accepter des
relations avec eux ? Et il il y a un
exercice très simple à faire. Je pense
que nous publierons bientôt quelque
chose dessus. Vous prenez d'un côté
l'Iran et de l'autre côté l'Arabie
Saoudite dans l'esprit des politiques et
dans la manière dont le dont les médias
présentent les choses. On a l'impression
que l'Arabie Saoudite est presque un
état respectable et que l'Iran est le
pire des États au monde. Quel que soit
le critère que vous prenez, application
de la peine de mort, nombre de personnes
décéd décédées, emprisonnement.
L'Iran l'Iran, l'Iran, par rapport à la
à son niveau de population, ils sont
quand même bien en tête. pendisons de
femmes.
Oui, mais les il y a le vous avez le
même nombre des de peines. Alors encore
une fois, je ne vous avez le même nombre
de peine capital en Iran qu'en Arabie
Saoudite pour un ratio de population de
1 à 4. Une femme peut être chef
d'entreprise en Iran. Euh leur système
n'est pas démocratique au sens
occidental du terme, c'est bien évident,
mais les luttes et les rapports de force
au sein du gouvernement iranien n'ont
rien à voir avec la structure familielle
de l'Arabie Saoudite. Euh l'Iran à jadis
financé du terrorisme le fait en partie
contre Israël. C'est ce sont des luttes
d'État à État. Aujourd'hui, l'Iran ne
finance pas ne finance pas le terrorisme
contre la France.
Euh on on est quel C'est lourd he ce que
vous vienez de dire.
Non mais c'est c'est très lourd entre
guillemets. On est sur deux états qui
sont pour moi en terme démocratique à
moins de 5/ 20 mais il y en a un qui est
à 4/ 20, il y en a un qui est à 2/ 20.
C'estd que l'Arabie Saoudite à tout
point de vue est bien pire que l'Iran.
Ah bah c'est c'est joyeux. Euh
euh revenons revenons sur les
États-Unis, la Russie. D'accord.
Maintenant, la Chine.
Que veut la Chine ?
Vaste question. Vaste question. Euh,
elle veut éviter de s'effondrer. Elle
veut maintenir ses 80 millions de de
partisans du Parti communiste. Elle veut
elle veut quoi ?
Alors, d'abord, je suis pas un spéci de
la Chine. J'ai longtemps travaillé dans
le sud-est asiatique avec eux ou contre
eux. Donc, je les ai plus vu de
l'extérieur et c'est pas nécessairement
euh je fais je fais à vœu de compétences
très très très limité. Je pense d'abord
il faut pas dire qu'est-ce que veut la
Chine parce qu'on on est on est là en ce
moment avec un régime particulier qui
est ce enfin le retour à une culte de la
personnalité au pouvoir assez comment
dire assez
ou centralisé de
actuel. Euh
je pense qu'on est d'une certaine façon
sur l'aspiration qu'on a toujours vu
dans l'histoire chinoise. Un de la
reconnaissance de de l'influence.
Bon, je je j'ai du mal à aller plus
loin. C'est que par certains côtés, je
suis extrêmement critique de la
politique chinoise en mer de Chine
méridienale et sur sur les franges où
juridiquement il n'ont aucun droit sur
ces îles. Ça a été prouvé de nombreuses
fois et c'est on le prouve d'autant
mieux que ce sont nous français qui
c'est nous français qui avons les
archives de
la mère de Chine, elle s'appelle maire
de Chine. Pourquoi ?
Non non mais c'est pas ça c'est qu' à
l'époque de de de l'Indochine coloniale,
il faut regarder ce que publiait
l'Institut des pêches d'Indochine dans
les années 29. On a déjà des on a les
premières photos des îles Spratle, on a
les photos des îles Paracel, on a on a
toute une série de choses qui qui là le
le la diplomatie française par ces
départements cartographiques, par ces
archives joue un rôle réel. Donc les
revendications chinoises sur ces zonesl
sont tout à fait inacceptables. Par
contre, les les Chinois sont aussi d'une
certaine façon poussés parfois dans le
retranchement par les Américains. Donc
on est là sur des jeux puis vous êtes
sur une puissance qui commence à se
rendre compte qu'elle est dominante,
qu'elle est extrêmement puissante et qui
va chercher à appliquer son à appliquer
son comment dire son effet de levier
partout où elle le peut dans le monde.
Je pense que c'est une menace probable à
moyen terme assez rapidement. Je pense
aussi que c'est la raison pour laquelle
Trump
cherche un rapprochement avec la Russie
mais qui ne peut pas faire directement
parce qu'il a bien compris qu'il fallait
que euh la Russie revienne dans le camp
occidental parce qu'à un moment donné,
il faudrait tempérer la montée en
puissance du pouvoir chinois, mais que
si évidemment lui euh prend cette
initiative, il va se faire assassiner
aux États-Unis et c'est probablement
pour ça qu'on a vu l'initiative
d'Emmanuel Macron l'été dernier. Vous
avez un avis positif sur Emmanuel
Macron, sur sa sa politique extérieure ?
Écoutez, je ne je neai
pas d'avis positif sur sa sur sa
politique extérieure, mais pas plus lui
que ses prédécesseurs hein, depuis le
revirement de Jack Chirac en 2003-2004
qui n'a pas été perçu à l'époque, euh ni
euh ni la politique extérieure de
Nicolas Sarkozy au moment des
révolutions arabes, ni la politique
inexistante de François Hollande, ni les
quelques décisions pro-américaines qui
ont été prises depuis le début du
quincana ne sont ne sont intéressantes.
Mais encore une fois, est-ce que nous
avons des hommes avec une longue
expérience et une longue compétence à la
gestion des affaires en politique
étrangère et en politique de défense ?
Aujourd'hui, dans les armées, oui.
Nos élites politiques sont quand même
d'une culture assez limitée sur ces
questions de politique étrangère et ça
ne fait pas partie du parcours et du
background d'Emmanuel Macron, aussi
intelligent soit-il.
C'est conseillé euh peut-être non.
Oui, probablement. probablement, mais
c'est quand même président qui décide,
surtout l'actuel.
Revenons, revenons sur le renseignement
économique.
Ouais.
Euh on dit euh euh renseignement
économique ou économie euh pardon,
excusez-moi, intelligence économique ou
économie de l'intelligence.
Ouais.
Pourquoi on dit ça ?
Alors, le j'entends peu parler du terme
économie de l'intelligence. Euh
peut-être veut-on éviter d'exercer
notalor mais non on on utilise le terme
intelligence économique depuis
maintenant euh assez longtemps qui à mon
sens
Robert Guillum non ?
Oui. Oui. Effectivement Robert est un
peu à l'origine de de tout ça. Feu
Robert est à l'origine de tout cela. Euh
un homme extraordinaire petit mais
extraordinaire.
L'expression n'est pas tellement
appropriée. On ferait mieux parler de
renseignement d'affaires ou de
renseignement commercial plutôt que
d'intelligence économique parce que
c'est vrai que ça ça nous fait penser
d'un côté à l'intelligence artificielle.
Bon, le l'expression est rentrée dans la
dans les dans les mœurs. Gardonsla
gardonsla. Mais c'est vrai qu'elle est
pas très elle n'est pas très heureuse.
On s'est fait avoir avec Alstom,
on s'est fait dépouiller notre filière
nucléaire. Hm
hm.
Maintenant, on s'est revendu à la
découpe avec la justice est en train
d'enquêter.
Euh, on l'a pas vu venir ou on a laissé
faire ?
Non, on l'a pas vu venir. On
n pas vu venir et on l'a laissé faire.
Oui, les deux. les deux. Mais si on l'a
laissé faire, c'est que non seulement on
l'a pas vu venir, mais on n pas les
outils pour lutter.
C'estàd que pour pour empêcher ça, il
aurait fallu disposer de moyens d'action
qui soient prévu qui était établi à
l'avance. Nous n'avons pas ça
aujourd'hui. C'est je on le disait tout
à l'heure sur le sujet de l'évolution de
la politique étrangère.
Le vouloir c'est une chose, avoir le
courage de le faire, s'en est une autre.
Mais est-ce qu'on dispose aujourd'hui
des moyens d'action ou de réaction ou de
protection ? parce que toute action
française générera des évolutions de
position des autres acteurs
internationaux. Donc c'est pareil dans
le monde du du renseignement économique
et des et de l'action concurrentielle
euh sur alors vous évoquiez l'affaire
Alstom et je rappelle que auparavant il
y a eu l'affaire BNP Paris-Bas
Technip Technipp
il y a Technipp il y a eu toute une
série d'attaques sur ce cité général
Arriva et d'autres d'autres viendront je
pense qu' je pense qu'il est important
de regarder ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
sur le marché de la grande distribution
en Amérique latine notamment au Brésil
où des actions de Walmart et du DOJ
pourrai à terme cibler des groupes comme
Casino Carrefour. Je suis je j'invite
les auditeurs à regarder de près ce qui
se passe parce que une nouvelle affaire
Alstom pourrait bien être voir le jour
sur place.
Euh non, nos élites ne sont pas
ne sont pas formées à cela. Ça au sens
propre ça va pas ça c'est pas dans leur
bande passante. En France, dès qu'on
fait du renseignement, on est tordu, on
est pervers. En fait, on souffre d'une
patologie très grave. On ne vous fait
pas confiance parce que soit on vous
considère comme tordu et pervers, soit
on vous attribue des talents
et on vous soupçonne de parler
systématiquement au 3e, au 4e ou au 5e
degré. Donc le niveau de méfiance et de
défiance est tel que finalement l'image
l'image de l'homme et maintenant des
femmes du renseignement est restée très
longtemps négative. Elle est elle
commence à évoluer et Dieu Dieu merci
c'est il faut il faut s'en réjouir mais
le problème c'est que les élites qui
sont aujourd'hui aux affaires continue à
fonctionner sur un sur un ancien modèle
et pour François Hollande c'est des
choses qui l'intéressait pas.
Et donc à partir du moment où les élites
n'ont pas cette formation, quelle que
soit la qualité des informations qu'on
leur apporte, des renseignements qu'on
leur donne, ça rentre pas dans leur
analyse.
Et mais c'est pas nouveau. Même Charles
Pasquais était un homme qui préférait,
il avait une forme de culture du
renseignement et du réseau, il préférait
s'informer par ses propres réseaux et
pas par ceux de l'État. Donc on on a
vraiment un défi, c'est améliorer une
culture et renseignement, comprendre que
aujourd'hui s'informer dans le monde tel
qu'il est, c'est de plus en plus
indispensable. D'ailleurs, n'oublions
pas que le renseignement est la première
étape de la stratégie. Et l'avantage,
enfin l'avantage et le désavantage du
métier du renseignement, c'est que ça
nous permet quand on est dans un
service, quand on est consultant en
entreprise, ça nous permet tout de suite
de voir s'il y a une stratégie ou pas
chez le donneur d'ordre qu'il soit
client, militaire, homme politique ou
enfin parlementaire ou ministre parce
qu'en fonction des alors encore une
fois, je vous parle de renseignement
offensif. Je ne parle pas de sécurité,
de contre-ingérence ou de
contrepionnage. En fonction de la la
manière dont sont posé les questions, on
mesure parfaitement qu'il y a pas de
vision ou qu'il y a pas de stratégie.
Et quand on en a, on est d'abord, on est
extrêmement content. Mais ça veut pas
dire que tout le travail est fait. C'est
qu'après il faut les habituer à gérer
l'information, savoir que nous
n'apportons pas toujours des réponses
sûres et définitives. Et et c'est pour
ça que je il est important de ne pas
rentrer dans la prédiction, dans la
prospective. Je ce sont des métiers à
part entière mais qui pour moi doivent
être déconnectés du renseignement.
Ça doit être un métier de civil.
Non non non, c'est un c'est un métier
qui peut être exercé par tous. Après, il
doit y avoir des organismes civils, des
organismes militaires, des organismes
policiers selon selon les Non, il y a
pas de
fait on fait comment pour contrôler du
moins comment le la société civile peut
contrôler ces services de renseignement.
D'abord, on va pas contrôler tous les
services de renseignement de la même
manière. Vous ne contrôlez pas le
service du renseignement territorial qui
mène peu d'actions clandestines de la
même façon que vous allez contrôler la
DGSI, la sécurité la DRSD, le
renseignement militaire ou le
renseignement extérieur. Euh c'est on
est là sur cinq sans oublier les autres,
on est là sur toute une série de types
de services qui ont des métiers
différents, donc des pratiques
différentes. Donc on peut pas appliquer
les les mêmes modes de de contrôle.
Certains relèvent de la loi française,
tous ceux qui travaillent sur le
territoire. La DGSE par exemple ne fait
que de l'espionnage, que de la
clandestinité.
Donc dire il s'agit comme comme on l'a
vu ces dernières années au cours des
premiers débats sur le contrôle
parlementaire dit dire il faut que la
DGSE fasse des choses légales.
Sincèrement c'est c'est complètement
parce que justement son métier c'est de
ne faire que des choses illégales
manipulé à l'étranger pour le bien de la
sécurité nationale. Ce qui a une
éthique, il y a une légitimité, il y a
une éthique. Ne croyons pas parce que
les femmes et les hommes du
renseignement font des choses qui ont
été popularisées, fantasmées, déformé
dans les dans les films d'espionnage qui
n'ont pas eux-mêmes des valeurs humaines
et de l'éthique quand ils décident de
choisir un agent dans une méthode de
recrutement. Alors bien sûr, c'est de la
casuistique. À un moment donné, on se
dit s'il faut éviter un attentat qui va
faire une centaine de victimes et qu'on
doit nous-même ruiner la vie de
quelqu'un, on peut se poser la question.
Mais donc les les modes de contrôle
doivent être très différents. Je pense
qu'il y a un domaine sur lequel le
contrôle doit enfin on doit pas
contrôler les opérations. D'ailleurs, il
y a peu de pays qui le font, les
États-Unis le font. Nous avons en France
une commission qui n'est pas une
commission de contrôle qui est une
délégation de suivi délégation
parlementaire au c'est quelque chose
finalement d'assez bien proportionné.
Parce que qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qui est
important ? c'est que les parlementaires
dans leur rôle dans leur rôle de de
contrôle de l'action gouvernementale
doivent pouvoir demander au gouvernement
s'il accorde les moyens suffisants au
service de renseignement en fonction du
niveau de la menace. Discuter avec les
patrons de service en leur demandant à
leur tour est-ce que vous êtes
suffisamment orienté par les autorités
politiques ? Est-ce que les deux est-ce
que les informations que vous remontez
sont prises en compte par les autorités
politiques ? et puis aller voir les
autorités politiques après s'il le faut
en disant "Mais suite à une discussion
avec un directeur du service, nous nous
apercevons que vous n'avez pas tenu
compte de l'information qu'il vous a
donné."
C'est ce qui se passe en Suisse. Les le
contrôle parlementaire suisse qui est
très intéressant fait qu'au bout de
trois fois où le patron du service de la
Fédération vient voir la la commission
de contrôle, il leur dit "Ça fait trois
fois que je passe telle information au
gouvernement fédéral, il en tient pas
compte." Et à ce moment-là, la
délégation parlementaire va dire "Nous
sommes les représentants, les élus de la
représentation nationale, on vous
demande d'en tenir compte. Il s'agit pas
de mettre le nez dans les opérations,
d'avoir le nom des sources, tout ça
c'est pas la peine. Par contre, les
parlementaires ont un deuxième rôle sur
les services de sécurité. La loi la loi
qui s'appelle loi sur le renseignement
en fait est une loi sur les services de
sécurité. C'est de bien noter la manière
dont on utilise les techniques de
renseignement sur le territoire national
pour que les les libertés publiques ne
soient pas bafouées euh systématiquement
et impunément.
Edward Snowen dit que on change les lois
euh pour légaliser le renseignement et
on change les lois à postériori pour
légaliser ce qui avait déjà été fait.
Oui, mais aux États-Unis, regardez, les
lois sur le renseignement chez
France aussi. Non
non, les lois sur le renseignement chez
nous
en France aussi quand même.
Non, ell elles elles ont une pour moi
une
non une limite c'est que enfin c'est le
cas de le dire. elles ont une limite
estce qu'elles ne sont pas limitées dans
le temps. La loi sur le renseignement
si on la met en place uniquement en
disant tous les 3 ans, on la réévalue,
et bien elle présente pas de danger
parce qu'une fois que le danger
islamiste a disparu, finalement un
certain nombre de mesures spéciales
peuvent être peuvent être suspendu.
Aujourd'hui, mettre une loi sur
renseignement sans limite de durée est
discutable parce qu'imaginons que nous
qu'un régime commun 1903 dans le cadre
d'une élection parlementaire libre
qu'un régime extrémiste arrive au
pouvoir, il aurait juridiquement et et
sur le plan législatif les moyens de
mettre le reste de la population sous
surveillance. Donc c'est c'est
c'est pas ce qui se passe en fait.
Snodon, il dit on change les lois pour
faciliter la surveillance.
Oui. Alors il il
Oui. Oui. Il évoque plusieurs choses. Il
évoque des pratiques.
Je dis qu'ils doivent probablement se
faire en France mais je n'en ai aucun
élément de de preuve mais je le vois
dans notre pays. C'est que vu que nous
ne pouvons pas et nous ne devons pas
espionner notre propre population par
des moyens techniques dans un certain
nombre de cas, nous le faisons faire par
nos alliés
et après on fait des changes de
renseignement. Alors je voilà par
exemple, imaginons que les Américains
écoutent ce qui se passe en Allemagne
parce que le BND ne peut pas le faire ou
le BFV ne peut pas le faire et donc il
donnent les informations les Allemands
et les Allemands vont surveiller
peut-être des citoyens américains aux
États-Unis ou ailleurs et donner les bon
sont des techniques de contournement qui
existent. Bon ceci dit très honnêtement
est-ce que notre démocratie est mise en
danger ? À la fois les lois ont quand
même des limites et deux il faut aussi
se poser la question que font encore une
fois les femmes et les hommes qui sont
dans les services ? La responsabilité
est quand même une enfin le sens de la
responsabilité de l'éthique est quand
même quelque chose qui qui existe et je
pense que nous dériverions nous aurions
un Edward Snowen français. Donc je suis
rassuré et rassurant pour l'instant sur
par rapport à cette situation.
La loi la loi sur la protection des
lanceurs d'alerte en France, la loi
Sapin.
Oui, mais elle elle est pas liée au
renseignement là. On est on est sur les
les méthodes anticorruption
dans ceur d'alerte. Oui oui oui. Mais
alors c'est un cas un peu différent.
Euh la loi de 2016 dit sapin 2 sur les
lanceurs d'alerte, elle est elle est
finalement pas c'est déjà une bonne
progression mais elle est encore mal je
dirais mal équilibrée. D'un côté, nous
voulons montrer que nous mettons en
place tous les dispositifs de conformité
nécessaires à lutter contre la
corruption notamment pour arrêter de se
faire avoir comme dans le cadre de
l'affaire Alstom par la justice
américaine. Euh et de l'autre nous
n'avons pas nous n'avons pas voulu aller
jusque dans les excès américains pour
les lanceurs d'alerte. Je crois que
Frédéric Pirucci qui était ici il y a
quelques semaines vous l'a expliqué. Aux
États-Unis, un lanceur d'alerte est
rémunéré.
Vous êtes un salarié, vous découvrez
qu'il y a de la corruption dans votre
entreprise, vous allez voir le FBI et en
fonction en fonction de du volume de
l'émission, vous allez toucher entre 10
et 30 % du montant de l'amende que va
payer l'entreprise au département de la
justice. Qu'est-ce que ça rentre ? C'est
c'est bien parce que pour le lanceur
d'alerte qui va perdre son job et qui va
probablement être backlisté pour toutes
les entreprises auxquelles il se
présentera, il aura il aura un revenu.
Mais en même temps, vous vous
encouragez,
vous accroissez et vous rémunérez la
délation.
Peut pas dire que ce soit quelque chose
de très glorieux, mais les lanceurs
d'alerte ont leur utilité. Donc notre
système en France n'est pas encore idéal
mais en tout cas, nous ne sommes pas
tombés dans l'excès américain.
On va passer à quelques questions de
d'internet. euh de de nos auditeurs. Il
y en a beaucoup hein, il y en a des
costauds. Euh les RG ont-ils quelques
infos sur Epstein de ses passages à
Paris ?
J'ignore absolument tout ce dossier
d'avrai.
C'est dommage.
Et la RG n'existe plus. Oui oui la la
DGSI
c'est dommage.
D'ailleurs d'ailleurs la fusion RG DST
initié par Sarkozy
2008 une véritable catastrophe où il y a
eu un écrémage de tous les gaulistes.
C'est pas l'écri, c'est la fusion des
deux services et la la le je dirais le
la domination de l'esprit des ST qui est
un excellent esprit en matière de
contre-espionnage pendant la guerre
froide mais qui n'est pas l'état
d'esprit le plus adapté à la période
moderne où l'information doit circuler.
Non, ça ça a été une on s'est tiré une
très belle balle dans le pied avec la
réforme de 2008.
Le vous parlez vous parlez on n plus
dans la guerre froide mais on n'est pas
en train d'y retourner là
avec qui ? Avec la Russie. avec avec la
Russie euh le les États-Unis.
Non non, je ne pour l'instant je ne
pense pas. Nous sommes dans un dans une
période de tension de nombreuses et
variées. Euh non, je ne crois pas qu'on
soit une paire de GF. Vous savez, d'une
certaine façon euh il y a quelque il y a
quelque chose de très intéressant. Euh
on s'aperçoit que la fin de la course
aux armements à la fin de la guerre
froide a ralenti en partie euh euh les
dépenses d'armement, la recherche
technologique et une partie de la
croissance mondiale parce que c'était
une activité très porteuse.
Le fait qu'il y ait une nouvelle
multiplication des tensions
internationales favorise d'une certaine
façon le redécollage de l'industrie
d'armement,
le vote des budgets notamment aux
États-Unis pour une pour toute une série
d'activités. Les Américains aujourd'hui
ont quasiment, je crois, un avion sur tr
dans l'US Air Force qui n'est pas en
état de volet. Ils doivent rénover toute
leur toute le tout leur arm nucléaire
qui arrive pour certaines pour une
partie à obsolescence. Donc, ils ont
besoin de se recréer un adversaire pour
se pour se déclencher les budgets. Je
crois qu'il faut plus voir là de la
gesticulation qu'une véritable volonté
ou une pardon que de dire "Nous sommes
dans une situation de guerre froide, ça
je n'y crois pas."
Ils sont pas en train de se créer un
adversaire et qui du moins leur leur
maintenant leur adversaire désigné,
c'est la population civile ?
Non, je ne le pense pas. Je pense que
nous avons une vision tout à fait
déformée de ce qui se passe aux
États-Unis parce que nos médias sont des
médias mainstream et ils ne reprennent
que les médias de mainstream américain.
Donc Donald Trump n'est certes pas la le
genre de beauté que nous voudrions avoir
à Paris et c'est peut-être pas l'idéal
pour les États-Unis, mais il bénéficie
d'un soutien populaire indéniable.
Si on se contente de lire le Washington
Post, New York Times et tous ces tous
ces grands journaux qui donnent le ton,
on a bien sûr une vision extrêmement
négative de ce qui se passe aux
États-Unis. Mais Trump a de grandes
chances d'être élu. il a donné
satisfaction à la population sur des tas
de points. Alors, on peut très bien dire
ça ça montre à quel point les Américains
sont idiots. Ils ont effectivement élu
George Bush il y a quelques années. Mais
malgré tout, ça montre qu'il y a une il
y a une véritable attente et il répond à
cette attente. Euh donc ne nous
intéresser ne nous intéresser à ce que à
ce que disent seulement les élites
américaines plutôt de gauche qui sont
issus des minorités qui sont vilipendées
par Trump he les noirs, les latinaux,
les juifs. Effectivement, il les
attaquent. Mais du coup, les points de
vue que donnent tous ces groupes de
pression sont pas ne représentent pas
nécessairement ce que pense l'Amérique
profonde.
Alors, une une question internet qui
n'est pas une question mais juste un mot
et vous comprendrez le mot tout de
suite.
L'affaire scripale,
Oui.
C'est quoi ? C'est un règlement de
compte des services en interne qui ont
été cherché une de leur taupe qui a qui
a bavé. C'est un ordre direct du
président. C'est quoi ? Alors, je vais
vous faire part d'une analyse mais qui
se base plus sur une expérience du
métier que sur des informations top
secret recoupé et validé. Euh, d'abord,
je crois qu'il faut commencer par dire
une chose, que Scripal aux yeux des
Russes est un traître et que quelqu'un
qui vend son pays dans un service de
renseignement, euh le sort qu'il a euh
qu'il a failli avoir, même si je ne lui
souhaite pas, euh n'est pas totalement
immérité quand on sait comment
raisonnent les services russes.
Deuxième chose,
à aucun moment, nous n'avons eu les
preuves explicites
de l'implication des services russes et
du président Poutine dans cette
tentative d'assassinat qui,
rappelons-le, a échoué parce qu'il y a
une affaire scriptale alors qu'il y a
pas eu mort d'homme.
Et on a vu la manière extrêmement
véhément avec laquelle ont réagit les
Britanniques sans apporter la moindre
preuve. Peut-être qu'ils en ont.
Peut-être que les le le Seécurity
service, le M5 a un certain nombre de
preuves, mais dans ce cas-là, que ne
disent-ils pas ? Donc où on le dit et on
argumente ou on n pas de preuve et dans
ce cas-là, le le comportement excessif
qui a été qui a été le leur et qui
finalement entraîné par des discussions
en off tous les pays européens et
occidentaux a expulsé, je crois 111
diplomates soviétiques au total. Et on
oublie que les russes, voyez, le le
vocabulaire reste coincé dans une partie
de mon cerveau. Les Russes de leur côté
on en fait on en a fait autant, on en a
moins parlé. Mais il y a eu d'une
certaine façon une attitude de soutien à
la décision à la décision britannique et
aux éléments qu' on avancé les
britanniques qui est excessive au regard
des éléments qu'ils ont donné. Euh alors
peut-être qu'ils ont donné des éléments
confidentiels en interne à d'autres,
mais en tout cas pour l'opinion, pour
les experts qui que nous sommes qui
n'avons pas accès à information
confidentielle, forcé de constater qu'il
n'y a pas de preuve. Il n'y a pas de
preuve.
Si on parlait un peu du Yémen et de la
politique française à à vendre des armes
à au chamulier coupeur de journalistes,
excusez-moi, c'est c'est sorti tout
seul.
Euh ça on va avoir encore des problèmes.
Vous savez ce que me disait un jour à
Damas il y a quelques en 2011, je vois
des adjoints de Chalan du PKK au cours
d'une mission d'évaluation et on se met
à parler de l'Arabie Saoudite et il me
dit c'était un curde syrien mais euh
dans non turchan mais euh et il me dit
mais les saoudiens c'est bédouins qui un
jour se sont réveillés sur un tas de
pétrole
les appeler chamelier
j'aurais dû les appeler bédoin
donc revenons au Yémen.
Euh
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? La France qui
envoie des canons César.
Euh notre ministre des armées qui dit
"Mais vous savez, c'est des armes
défensives.
Euh euh
on on tortit du cul." Non,
disons qu'on onge en pleine
contradiction euh parce qu'on soutient
euh l'Arabie Saoudite et surtout nos
amis des Émirats avec lesquels les
relations sont très bonnes et qui sont
dans leur genre plus respectables que
leurs voisins Qatari
et Saoudien. Il y a une abrication de
lutte. C'est pour moi quelque chose de
de d'assez scandaleux que cette guerre
au Yémen qui n'est pas couverte comme
elle le devrait par les médias en tout
cas qui commence seulement à l'être dans
situation absolument humanitaire.
horrible euh qui n'est pas loin de
s'approcher de celle de la Syrie, qui
pourtant a bénéficier d'une couverture
infiniment plus importante euh dans
lequel en plus il y a une politique
saoudienne de destruction systématique
de tous les de tout le patrimoine
archéologique
des hôpitaux. Alors c'est et et nous
soutenons ça directement ou
indirectement par de la fourniture de
renseignement, par de la fourniture de
munition, par et nous sommes pas les
seuls hein, les les les Américains le
font encore davantage que nous et
d'autres occidentaux, ils sont et mais
nous sommes là dans la sonorité
occidentale et dans sonorité avec nos
pourvoyeurs de fond et mais nous n'avons
cessé de prendre les mauvais choix sur
l'Égypte,
sur la Syrie.
Comment voulez-vous qu'une politique
française cohérente a lieu quand elle ne
fait que des erreurs parce qu'elle
essaie de combiner parfois
des idéaux issus de la révolution
démocratique, des intérêts puis le point
de vue qui leur vient des États-Unis
puis ce que peuvent dire les médias pour
qu'on soit dans le mainstream.
Il aurait fallu faire quoi avec la Syrie
?
Parce que Bachar et la salad il est pas
tout blanc.
Ah mais c'est indéniable. les les barils
plein de TNT qui balancent sur des
civils des
Mais je suis d'accord mais c'est une
guerre
donc espérer qu'il n'y ait pas de mort
et qu'il n'y ait pas trop dans une
guerre c'est malheureusement croire
croire au père Noël surtout dans ces
régimesl et les Syriens sont pas des
enfants de cœur et ce sont pas des gens
tendres et quand ils font la guerre ils
la font pas avec des gants blancs dans
les deux que ce soit les Syriens ou puis
en plus c'est pas un régime démocratique
donc le respect de la vie humaine n'a
pas la même valeur. On est tous d'accord
là-dessus. Seulement, la question qu'on
doit se poser un, c'est pourquoi Bachar
est-il resté au pouvoir ?
Soutenu par
ça veut d'abord dire qu'il y a 51, 52 ou
55 % de la population qui le
soutiennent,
qui n'ont pas envie de se faire
hiraquiser.
Mais attendez, entre les barbus et un
régime autoritaire, on préfère un régime
autoritaire. Enfin, je me mets à leur
place. Je suis allé de nombreuses
reprises à Damas à pendant le pendant le
pendant le conflit. D'abord, les
destructions
étaient beaucoup moins importantes qu'on
nous le montrait. Les images étaient et
je le dis avec avec certitude était
manipulé notamment combien de fois on
nous a montré des images de Gaza à feu
et à sang pour simuler les combats
d'Alpes. J'étais encore l'année dernière
à Alep. Les trois/4 de la ville à part
des éclats d'armes légères sont à peu
près intacts hein. Les gens ils mangent
des glaces.
On trouve et c'est ça qui est
merveilleux en Syrie, c'est quand même
le seul endroit du proche Orient où on
trouve une mosquée entourée d'église ou
une église entouré de mosquée. Il y
avait vraiment une cohabitation des
religions entre les les les catholiques,
les Grecs orthodoxes, les sunnites qui
étaient absolument extraordinaire. Et ça
pour des Saoudiens, pour des Qataris,
c'est insupportable. C'est absolument
insupportable. Alors encore une fois,
Bachar n'est pas un saint, nous sommes
d'accord. Mais un
fallu faire quoi ?
Ah, je ne sais pas ce qu'il aurait fallu
faire. Il y a eu tout ce que vous
décrivez juste hein. Il a fait un
certain nombre d'attaque. La seule les
seules choses sur lesquelles nous nous
sommes systématiquement euh insurgés,
c'est que à chaque
Est-ce que les frappes chimiques euh ça
a pas été un petit peu instrumentalisé ?
Si je pense que les les frappes
chimiques ont été instrumentalisées, en
tout cas celles de 2013 puis de 2016 qui
ont servi de justificatif à des à des
réactions qui ont lieu ou qui n'ont pas
eu lieu d'ailleurs euh était à mon sens
fausse. D'ailleurs, j'invite les
téléspectateurs à écouter le rapport de
Carla del Panté qu'elle avait fait après
les soi-disants frappes de 2013 en
disant quand même la mission de l'ONU en
disant "Nous n'avons aucune preuve de
l'implication de de Bachar. Mon but
n'est pas de blanchir Bachar. Mon but
c'est d'expliquer aux gens qui nous
écoutent que systématiquement si on s'en
remet au médias et si on écoute les
argumentations des services parce que
parfois les services sont
instrumentalisés ou se mettent eux-mêmes
dans la logique de complaisance
vis-à-vis du gouvernement et bien c'est
il nous en fume. Il nous en fume. Et
donc la fameuse note du SGDSN qui avait
été faite non pas par les services mais
qui avait été un copiercollé de
différents articles pour justifier la
politique française ne tient pas la
route. Il y a des experts qui
connaissent la Syrie encore mieux que je
je la connais et qui vous l'expliqueront
qui vous l'expliqueront. Donc le but
n'est pas de blanchir Bachar. Le but est
de dire pourquoi est-ce que nous avons
essayé de mentir à tel point pour
l'éliminer ? Alors j'insiste aussi sur
sur sur différents points. J'ai assisté
à plusieurs reprises à Damas, à Alep, à
des cérémonies religieuses dans
lesquelles on trouvait des chiites, des
sudnites, des chrétiens qui appelaient à
la fin de la guerre. Et quand on
discutait avec ces gens-là et avec
l'opposition l'opposition syrienne que
je moi je suis allé voir à plusieurs
reprises à à Damas, des gens qui avaient
euh qui avaient fait 14 20 25 ans de de
prison, qui étaient des opposants à
Bachar Alassad et à son père et qui n
torturé ou pas
certains torturaient bien sûr qui nous
disaient mais entre Bachar et ce qu'il y
a en face, on préit faire Bachard et qui
nous disait surtout vous les Européens,
vous êtes en train de soutenir qui ?
Vous soutenez des frères musulmans qui
ont quitté le pays depuis des années,
qui ont fait des massacres en 82 parce
qu'il faut pas oublier que les
événements de de de
lorsque les frères musulmans sont
rentrés et ont égorgé 70 cadets à
l'école militaire de
de Hamma ou de Hom, si j'ai un trou de
mémoire, ça a pas été des enfants de
cœur et la réaction de l'armée syrienne
était horrible. Ils ont ils ont détruit
la moitié de la ville qui était au mains
des frères musulmans pour se venger. On
est c'est pas de la guerre à
l'occidentale malheureusement le le la
protection des populations n'existe pas.
Mais quand on discute avec c cette
opposition qui était la véritable
opposition historique et démocratique à
à au père de de Bachar et puis à Bachar,
ces gens-là nous disaient "Mais pourquoi
vous soutenez des frères musulmans
d'abord qui sont implantés à l'étranger
depuis des années, qui ne représentent
pas l'opposition démocratique à Bacher
Alassad et qui vont faire le jeu de
l'Arabie Saoudite." Donc cette cet
aveuglement ou cette volonté de ne pas
voir est absolument insupportable.
Et après on on noir enfin comme
d'habitude
on dit que son chien l'arrache pour les
miner. Encore une fois, Bachar n'est pas
un saint, mais on présente aujourd'hui
le conflit comme si sur les 3600 morts,
l'armée syrienne, on avait fait 355000
et que les pauvres islamistes avaient
tué 5000 personnes. Mais combien de fois
des chrétiens de enfin des des individus
tout obidéans sont été Bachar était de
toute façon soutenu par la minorité
chrétienne. Ça veut pas dire qu'il le
portait dans leur cœur par la
bourgeoisie sunnite qu'on trouvait à
Damas et à parce qu'elle avait besoin
que les affaires tournent pour faire du
business par la minorité alaouit. Bien
qu'il y ait eu aussi des alaouites euh
dans dans l'opposition sur le plan
combattant par les petites minorités
chites, il y en a pas énormément.
Ça ça veut dire que quand même il y
avait une partie de la population
majoritaire, même si elle est
majoritaire de manière limitée, qui de
manière tout à fait pragmatique se
disait probable enfin on aime pas ce
régime, on aime pas ce type mais entre
lui et les autres il y a pas photo. Et
nous avons voulu, nous occidentaux,
imposer notre point de vue d'ailleurs en
essayant de tromper en partie l'opinion
sur la réalité de la situation sur place
et de modifier la politique régionale et
encore une fois encore sous impulsion
américaine, saoudienne et
Qatarie. Et pour quel résultat ? Un
échec complet. Bachar n'est pas tombé.
Une petite question d'internet. vision
de l'invité sur la position de l'Europe
militaire économique politique à moyen
long terme. Là, on est parti pour 1hure
et demi. On va on va synthétiser ça par
l'Europe de la défense. Vous y croyez ?
Non, je n'y crois pas.
Nous conseillons au CF2R les
institutions européennes sur un certain
nombre de questions depuis quelques
temps.
Il y a des gens absolument formidables
mais plus on travaille moins j'y crois.
Autre question d'internet ?
Comment la France peut réagir face au
département of justice et leurs OPA sur
nos entreprises stratégiques françaises
? Est-ce qu'il n'est pas déjà trop tard
? On en a déjà parlé. Vous voulez
rajouter un petit mot ? Non, c'est
jamais trop tard. Le problème c'est que
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on peut reprendre
la main sur
un certain nombre de de d'éléments
critiques qui vont fournir de l'énergie,
des turbines et turbo alternateurs à nos
bâtiments de guerre, à nos à nos
centrales nucléaires
et surtout l'enjeu c'est est-ce qu'on
pourra récupérer un jour tous les
brevets qui sont les résultats du
travail des femmes et des hommes des
ingénieurs français depuis des années
qui sont partis à l'extérieur. Ça c'est
c'est quelque chose de scandaleux. Euh
si nous mettions en place aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de choses, nous pourrions
à un moment donné non pas tenir tête. Il
est pas question de de de rêver un jour
qu'on qu'on fasse un jeu à armes égales
contre les États-Unis. Le différentiel
de puissance est énorme, mais on peut
avoir les moyens euh de de limiter la
casse et de le remettre à leur place
parfois.
CF2R et les entreprises françaises.
Artémis, on comprend pas la question.
Euh alors une question sur nos liens
avec le Kosovo.
Est-ce que est ce gouvernement lié au
terrorisme et à la mafia ? Question de
Nicolas avec un cas.
Écoutez, je j'avoue que j'ai du mal à
comprendre la question.
Nos relations avec le Kosovo, est-ce que
on est lié avec un bon, je comprends pas
trop la question non plus, mais bon. Euh
question de monsieur WoW. Trump qui vire
John Bolton la veille du 11 septembre,
c'est un signal fort envoyé à la suite
en Iran.
Oui, probablement la suite en Iran.
Oui, je je personne n'intéresse qu'il y
a un conflit au Moyen-Oriement. Puis
n'oublions pas une chose, Trump est un
homme d'affaires. C'est pas un vat en
guerre. À la différence de Bolton qui
était probablement un très grand malade
dans la matière. Trump aime les
négociations difficiles.
Ce qu'il amuse, c'est la enfin je je je
j'extrapole, mais j' dire ce qu'il amus,
c'est la guerre commerciale avec l'Iran,
c'est de pouvoir avec la Chine, c'est de
pouvoir tweeter, c'est de jouer les
rapports de force. Très honnêtement,
d'après tous les éléments don dont on
dispose, je je ne vois pas là un homme
qui souhaite un vat en guerre
irresponsable. Il est c'est un bluffeur,
hein, n'oublions pas que c'est un homme
du secteur de l'immobilier new yorkaais.
Il faut connaître la psychologie des
gens du secteur immobilier new yorkais.
C'est c'est quelque chose d'assez
particulier et il en présente toutes les
caractéristiques. Donc je bluffe, je
commence à montrer mes biceps avant de
avant de négocier puis je fais marche
arrière. On l'a vu sur la Corée, on le
voit sur on le voit sur l'Iran. La
situation iranienne est plus complexe.
Il y a quand même des très forts
courants anti-iran qui existent aux
États-Unis et puis nos amis israéliens
ne sont pas non plus pour rien dans le
changement de la politique américaine
par rapport à l'accord de 2015. Mais je
pense que c'est d'abord une excellente
nouvelle qu'on y verrait Bolton euh
parce que effectivement il ça c'était
c'était un fauteur de trouble euh
terrible. Je pense que l'enjeu pour
autre homme c'est d'essayer de refaire
un terme du business avec l'Iran et
c'est possible en récupérant tout en
écartant les entreprises européennes
comme Peugeot.
Mais comme Peugeot, vous savez, je l'ai
vécu en Birmanie en 95. Je je faisais
partie de l'équipe qui assurait la
sécurité du chantier de total en zone de
guerrière. Nous avons étroinga, on
mettra un petit mot d'ailleurs.
Ouais. Nous avons été attaqués par
toutes les organisations des droits de
l'homme et Total a été condamné de
manière extrêmement dure dans les médias
pour pour des actions qui n'a jamais
commises. On nous accusait de de
collision avec le régime de Rangun. Bon,
tout cela était évidemment faux et
déformé. Mais ce qui se passait en
réalité derrière ça, c'est que vu que
les entreprises américaines en tout cas
jusqu'à ce que Total commençait à
exploiter ce gisement de gaz qui était
en merde dans n'avait pas le droit de
faire des affaires avec la Birmanie. Ça
les défris de voir que des entreprises
européennes et des entreprises
françaises puissent faire des affaires
avec la Birmanie parce qu'ils
attendaient eux une seule chose, c'est
que le régime euh ce qu'ils appelaient
le Slor à l'époque, ce nom qui claque
comme un coup de fouet qui était le
l'aginte militaire de Rangun s'écroule
qu'Assasunchi prenne la suite et que
tous les vu qu'ils avaient soutenu
Assonsuchi pendant des années et sa
National League for Democra qui puisse
récupérer tous les contrats et à partir
du moment où il voyait des entreprises
européennes qui commençaient à
s'installer et à faire des affaires à
leur détriment, il se disait
Ils vont ils vont prendre des positions
fortes qu'on aura peut-être du mal à
déloger après. Et pendant la période où
nous travaillons sur place avec Total et
toutes les équipes de de sécurité de
renseignement qui assuraient la sécurité
du chantier, on voyait très bien comment
les guerriillas adverses que je
respectais parce qu'effectivement lutter
contre le régime de Rangou était une
chose que je trouvais légitime mais
était parfois financé par les Américains
pour venir organiser des attaques contre
le chantier total. Donc cette guerre
économique, elle a parfois des aspects
violents aussi. Les roingas, ça fait 40
ans qu'on en parle, ça fait 40 ans
qu'ils se font massacrer.
Oui. Alors, c'est d'abord, c'est triste,
c'est quand même énormément monté en
épingle par les médias internationaux.
Je je me suis peu intéressé, je connais
bien sûr le pays où j'ai vécu, je me
suis peu intéressé à cette question là
parce que euh tout simplement parce que
j'ai pas le temps ce moment. Mais le le
seul élément qui m'a frappé depuis le
début, c'est qu'il y a plusieurs
communautés musulmanes en Birmanie.
Or, seule celle-ci est poursuivie.
Seule celle-ci a attaqué aussi des
postes de police. Alors, je ne dis pas
que ce sont eux qui ont provoqué les
choses. Ils sont victimes.
Persécuté depuis un certain nombre
d'années, ils en peut-être un peu marre,
non ?
Oui, mais les choses sont pas aussi
simples que ça. Après, la réaction a été
totalement excessive de la part du
gouvernement Birmand et mais regardez,
jamais Hassan Succhi n'a pris une
position claire sur le sujet.
On est sur un dossier qui a jamais été
vraiment étudié en détail. Encore une
fois, il y a des massacres humanitaires
indéniables.
Une question, une question internet
qu'on va un peu muscler.
Vous croyez à la théorie de
l'effondrement ? Est-ce que vous pensez
que les marchés financiers vont tenir le
coup ? Est-ce que vous pensez qu'on on
va Est-ce qu'on va est-ce qu'on va dans
le mur ? Est-ce qu'on va dans le mur
très vite
avec des gens aveugles au volant ?
D'abord, je suis pas économiste, j'ai
beaucoup de mal à me faire
Oui. Oui. Non, non, mais peut-être mais
ce que je à travers ça, c'est que c'est
ça fait partie des questions que je me
pose et d'ailleurs qu'on étudie en
partie avec l'équipe. Euh
même si j'essaie d'être neutre, ne
serait-ce que sur le débat faut-il
rester ou sortir de l'euro qu'elles
seront on a un mal fou à faire à faire à
se faire un point de vue même en
écoutant les meilleurs experts des deux
corps. sur l'effondrement économique
mondial. Je veux dire les les les
critères qui nous intéressent en ce
moment, c'est il y a quand même beaucoup
de cash et d'argent qui circulent
partout partout. Euh
pourquoi est-ce que cet argent-là n'est
pas investi ?
On pourrait à quelque chose près, quand
on voit les sommes d'argent qui
circulent, résoudre le problème du
développement de l'Afrique
en 2 ans.
Bon parce que effectivement tous ceux
qui sont derrière ces masses monétaires
énormes virtuelles qui circulent sont
dans la recherche de retour sur
investissement et non pas sur sur le
développement international. Et donc il
y a de plus en plus une déconnexion
entre une économie réelle et une
économie virtuelle. Et j'avoue que ça ça
donne le vertige, mais j'ai très
honnêtement j'ai pas la capacité pour
analyser ça.
Le proe d'un officier de ronnement,
c'est quand on sait quand on ne sait
pas.
Ouais. Ou de sortir ses rames pour se
barrer. C'est ça. On arrive à la fin de
notre interview.
Euh est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner
trois livres à lire ?
Alors,
le secret de l'Occident de David Cosandé
qui est un physicien suisse euh de je je
crois que c'est le c'est c'est paru dans
la collection Champflamarion. C'est un
petit livre jaune. C'est un livre
absolument extraordinaire qui explique
en dehors de toute théorie raciste la
raison pour lesquelles l'Europe et
l'Occident ont dominé le monde
pour des raisons historiques, pour des
raisons géographiques, climatiques.
C'est un livre qui est tout à fait
alimentaire alimentaire.
Non, il y a des a il y a des
expressions, il y a des il y a des
explications sociopolitiques. Ce livre
est est connu dans les milieux
universitaires. Il est trop méconnu
parce qu'il est tout à fait il est
vraiment tout à fait remarquable et je
pense que c'est aussi une antidote
merveilleuse à la culpabilité dans
laquelle nous vivons aujourd'hui
vis-à-vis d'un d'un certain nombre de
comment dire de
personnes alors de nos sociétés ou du
tiersmonde qui veulent nous faire
regretter notre passé et ce qui a été ce
qui a été produit et ce qui était devenu
depuis depuis des années. Ce livre fait
vraiment partie pour moi euh presque des
explications géopolitiques méconnues qui
méritent d'être d'être approfondi et je
le dis d'autant plus que Cindé est à la
fois suisse donc issu d'un pays qui n'a
pas de décision de coloniale et qu'il
est physicien et pas du tout
géopolitologue. Donc c'est c'est une
c'est une analyse extrêmement
intéressante qui n'a d'ailleurs aucune
portée qui n'a aucun jugement, aucune
portée morale et qui est factuellement
extrêmement intéressante. Je vous
coupe. Vous pensez qu'on va dans le mur
ou pas ?
On a beaucoup de signes qui nous amènent
qui nous amènent à penser qu'on va dans
le mur. En tout cas, l'évolution de nos
sociétés est quand même extrêmement
extrêmement préoccupante. Alors, est-ce
que c'est la période de trouble qui
caractérise le passage d'un d'un ancien
système à un nouveau système ? Est-ce
que nous allons être dans une période de
troupe permanente et que finalement on
va trouver des façons de gérer les
équilibres instables ? Où est-ce que
nous allons dans le mur ? C'est
extrêmement difficile à dire. Ce que
j'observe, c'est que ce qu'on voit comme
crise dans la cité française, on le voit
tout aussi bien dans les pays voisins
avec lesquels nous nous travaillons
assez régulièrement. Croyons pas que
l'Italie va mieux, que l'Allemagne va
mieux. Il y a des points positifs, il y
a des points négatifs. La crise en
Grande-Bretagne est absolument
aérissante pour ce pays qui a été
pendant longtemps d'une stabilité et une
référence terrible. Je crois que l'autre
problème que nous mesurons peu, il est
enfin il y en a quelques-uns qui sont
pour moi des critères importants, c'est
que nous sommes dans des sociétés de
plus en plus éruptive
et donc qui vont générer le pass le le
le ralliment d'individus à des causes de
plus en plus extrêmes. Pourquoi ? Parce
que nos sociétés aujourd'hui se
caractérisent par un accroissement du
temps libre et du désovrement. On rentre
plus tard dans la vie active, on est au
chômage une partie de sa vie active et
quand on termine sa carrière, on est en
retraite et on a beaucoup de temps
libre. Donc il faut meubler le temps
libre.
Deuxième élément qui est concomitant,
nous sommes dans une période de
recherche de sens ou de perte de valeur,
peu importe le dit. Donc ça veut dire
que le temps libre va être en plus
orienté. On va chercher quelque chose
qui nous donne un sentiment de de nous
raccrocher à une valeur qui peut guider
notre vie. Et troisème aspect, nous
avons les technologies de l'information
qui fait que vous mettez les trois
piliers ensemble. Vous avez
l'explication de la montée en puissance,
de mouvement d'extrême droite, d'extrême
gauche, d'animalistes, d'écologistes
radicaux, de d'antiavortement de et avec
en plus des phénomènes très
intéressants, c'est que les individus et
je pense que nous tous nous en sommes
l'expression d'une certaine manière,
nous attendons systématiquement la
satisfaction immédiate de nos
aspirations. Et donc, si nous ne sommes
pas satisfaits de ce que nous exigeons
en tant que citoyens consommateur dans
la journée, dans le mois ou dans
l'année, nous passons à l'action
contestataire ou violente. Et on voit
quels que soient les sujets aujourd'hui
cette cette dérive vers les extrêmes.
Notre Dame d'Eland euh
Notredame des Landes les extrêmes, vous
êtes allé les voir un peu les
Oui. Mais c'est essay développé
aujourd'hui
vous avez été sur le terrain à Notredame
des Landes ?
Oui. En périphérie. Je ne suis pas
rentré dans les zones. Pourquoi
vous avez pas pu rentrer ?
Parce que j'ai pas cherché à le faire.
Ce qui m'intéressait c'est de
un renseignement de terrain mon ami.
Bien évidemment mais c'est il y a des
gens qui font ça et qui sont payés pour
le faire. Mais je je termine. Notredame
en un exemple, c'est la convergence des
luttes. On va trouver des encore une
fois je ne porte pas de jugement de
valeur sur le fait, on pourrait en
parler plus longuement, mais ce qui
m'intéresse, c'est le phénomène
sociologique qui est derrière ça. Des
sociétés ultra éruptives,
du temps libre, du désovrement. Alors si
on rajoute à ça de la crise économique,
personne pour donner naissance. Le
deuxième élément important, c'est que
nous sommes dans des sociétés où il y a
plus de différentiel entre les élites et
la population. Il y a encore une ou deux
générations, nos parents et nos
grands-parents pouvaient dire les gens
qui nous gouvernent savent ce qu'ils
font. Ils ont fait des études.
Aujourd'hui, nous avons tous dans
l'environnement des gens qui sont au
pouvoir le même niveau d'étude. Donc
nous avons tendance plus facilement à
juger ce qu'ils font, à le critiquer, à
le mettre en doute à juste titre ou à
mauvais titre. Ce qui entraîne en plus
d'ailleurs de la contestation
systématique et ce qui veut dire que ça
devient probablement de plus en plus
difficile de gouverner, qu'il n'y a plus
de primuté intellectuelle de la part des
des membres du gouvernement ou du
parlement sur le reste de la population.
Les souvent, j'ai envie de vous dire,
les plus intelligents ne sont pas
rentrés en politique. Donc tout ça est
en train de de changer le système. Puis
il y a un tr un troisème élément que je
trouve particulièrement important, c'est
que nous sommes de plus en plus dans une
société où les la multiappartenance
existe à tous les niveaux.
Il y a encore une ou de génération en
France, il y avait 95 % de Français et 5
% de binationaux. Aujourd'hui, de plus
en plus, on voit des gens qui sur un
plan culturel, qui sur un plan
religieux, qui sur un plan de
nationalité ont deux appartenances ou
trois appartences. Et ça, c'est un fait
dont on doit tenir compte. mais sur les
notions de patriotisme, sur les notions
d'homogénéité d'un groupe, c'est en
train de et quand on commence à mettre
tous ces ingrédients qui ne sont que la
partie à laquelle je m'intéresse moi, je
pense qu'on a déjà un mélange explosif,
mais il peut sortir aussi quelque chose
de bien parfois de d'une explosion.
Deux autres bouquins.
Euh deux autres. Alors, je vous ai dit
causandé. Euh
écoutez, pour sortir un lisez les
nourritures terrestres de Gide.
C'est c'est toujours merveilleusement
c'est merveilleusement merveilleusement
écrit. Euh et puis
parce que je vous je le dis, on lit pas
assez euh et surtout on ne lit plus
assez de littérature et je crois qu'il
faut lire le roman de euh enfin le livre
de de Romain Gary qui s'appelle à
l'homme qui fut la France qui est une
une apologie du général de Gaulle mais
qui est absolument merveilleuse.
On
on a l'habitude de toujours terminer
notre interview euh par laisser un
conseil pour les jeunes générations. Une
bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
d'impérissable sur les réseaux.
Laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Ouais. travaillez mettez les choses en
doute mais c'est ça
deessé merci
merci de votre invitation
[Musique]